jeez the Heat's going to kill me chefs
say the heat of the kitchen either makes
you or breaks you this week I meet a
chef who it nearly
killed he claps in the kitchen he's just
been rushed to hospital I hope the hell
he's
[Music]
okay nwit a wealthy chesher town in the
part of a thriving farming Community
just off the High Street is Oscars named
after Irish writer Oscar wild it's been
hard work like I've put a lot of money
into it and I want it to work out now
I'm running out the
excuses Kathy you you short out
the thank you very much 12 months ago
with the support of her family Mora puts
65,000 her life savings into opening her
dream restaurant I like I like meeting
people I I love meeting people and this
is what I
enjoy one big happy family running a
quaint Irish restaurant
perfect trouble is Mo is now losing two
grand a week and this place was meant to
be her Pension Plan it's just a
nightmare it really is it is a nightmare
it's it's a panic especially when I'm on
my own you know I have nobody to go home
and say God you know what do you you
think Mora can't afford a head chef so
her son Lennon's headling up the kitchen
for free I'm the one that's closest to
me long so obviously I wouldn't see an
allerg and that's it I just
stayed but even with Lennon's charitable
contribution it seems Oscars is on its
last legs [__] me it's on top of a
butcher be are you well I'm very well
it's Mora Mora good beara bigara this is
a cozy nice who's that on the ball down
there who do you think it is it looks
like a fat version of Jonathan Ross
Lenny how you doing please to meet you
and you what's under here they are the
ribs which um cook in Coca-Cola cooked
in Coca-Cola yeah [__] me that's a new
one Hest to God they are they're cooked
in Coca-Cola in Coca-Cola okay Lennon
used to be a pub chef and it looks like
he's picked up some bad
habits and what style of food is it I
call a bit of everything
fish steaks bit of pasta bit of
vegetarian try to cover a bit of
everything oh dear I can't wait to find
out what More's athletic menu has to
offer okay thank you King Porn wrap
green lit muscle soup dour a little bit
of everything a good restaurant does one
sort of food brilliantly a bad one does
50 badly Oscar wild buffalo buffalo in
chesa even I'd find more as menu a
challenge Gordon's having a p small God
knows how her son Lenin copes he wants a
carbonara for his means oh the
B you had to pick the thing I'm wor that
oh thank you my P starter takes 20
minutes to arrive so a nice um
psychedelic pink
crabstick it stinks as well then like
everyone else I start
waiting and waiting for my my main
course oh for [__] sake what are they
doing in there lots of Cuttery on the
table but no [__]
food has anyone told them there are 38
customers in the
restaurant tables three and seven have
been cleared for about 20 minutes
f
f with food and service this bad
firsttime customers will never come back
somebody's having a laugh here here one
has complained about waiting so long for
the food now they want a bottle of
complimentary wine what can you do you
have to get the customer happy Mo has
been forced to flush what little profit
she could be making straight down the
toilet
somebody thank you at last an hour and a
half after ordering it my carbonara
finally arrives tastes like there's
vinegar
there you don't put [__] vinegar in a
carbonara
no egg in there there's no parmesan in
there it's bland it's garlicky chicken's
rubbery apart from being crap and really
[__] I actually feel really embarrassed
cuz the girls behind me haven't even
eaten yet we've been in here since 8:00
and it's now 10 10 so we kind of gone a
bit past caring of what
comes I'm amazed they've held out this
long what's going on in there lenon is
really [__] embarrassing me out there
let me uh let me give you a hand so um
who's commun who's communicating who's
who's doing what anyone in what's that
down there who put that under there
obviously the smoldering 35° heat in
this kitchen has started to scramble
their brains who put it under the grill
guys I put and did you look after it Les
well I just assumed they saw me put it
right next to me when I did it this is
like a [__] Lauren Hardy
Show this is another fine mess I've got
myself
into Sal
V or three Sal
Veg it's a fast veg is over is that to
CED with mother and son playing the bla
game where is
it there's no where it's going the [__]
off this is the problem we have most of
the time [__]
waitresses no one has taking control T 2
is now looking for some discount I'd say
get [__] oh you you can't do that you
don't speak to custom two Bott of wine
TOS that's like nearly three yeah but
you can't speak to a customer like that
well I [__] disagree well I I S what
I'm just saying the F this kitchen's a
pressure cooker waiting to explode like
a two R anyway let's not argue let's
just try and get some food out let [__]
off [__] [__] [__] yourself a head
chef who can't stand the
heat what happened to the quaint family
on
restaurant [__] me it's not normal this
you know this is not [__] normal huh
doing your m a favor is one thing man
helping to run her business into the
ground is another you can't be happy
with this it does hurt to say it because
I know that every penny your mom's got
is in her house is in this everything's
in
this this
[__] I apologize so much Mo's given away
over100 worth of free drink and food
should have been better off closing for
the night and saving the restaurant's
reputation L stand next to your mom I
actually sat down with a little bit of
excitement you know that thinking Christ
this is quain this is beautiful then
when the food arrived trust me I don't
think quite honestly we need to hear any
more bad comments on the food tonight
cuz I've had a [__] belly F we're in
the
[Music]
[__]
morning morning it's my second day at
Oscars last night mother and son team
MOA and lennin ran possibly the worst
service I've ever seen the first thing
that struck me when I came into the
kitchen last
night was the disrespect between mother
and son that was a big shock for me yes
um with it being a family business you
know this is like a livelihood and I
walked out and I I do
know that you know that wasn't right
what the [__] happened last night um you
give it to me truthfully truthfully um
and seriously and seriously I
um I was nervous about the whole thing
and I did and I'll openly admitted to
have a few drinks yesterday waking up to
it
and basically through that I did lose my
concentration of what I was doing
everything just went pearshaped if I am
going to get involved and start working
[__] hard to help get this thing back
on track you've really got to promise me
that you're going to concentrate not
disappear and forget anything about a
[__] drink
100%
110% I promise you that I'm really
worried about linen tur into alcohol
every time there's pressure in the
kitchen so many shfs go down that line
and if it's not alcohol it's drugs and
that's the last thing you need when
you're under pressure it's a [__]
recipe for
disaster like his dad before him
Lennon's always wanted to be a chef but
so far I've seen nothing revolutionary
in his cooking it's time to find out
just what lights his fire I don't cook
for myself you don't [__] eat your
own food are you keen on anything Cy I
just like vindaloo Cy for some reason
vindoo yeah no I'm red not said I'm sit
I'll sit with a bottle of wine with that
and I'm happy enough so you eat Velo you
smoke 40 cigarettes a day a bottle of
wine sugar sandwiches sugar what sugar
sandwiches how the [__] B the bread and
dip it into the Sugar Bowl
gorgeous trust me you must have a pet
like a cow's bat side having F diarrhea
you know that Sugar sandwiches and ribs
brazed in
Coca-Cola Lenin's taste buds have
clearly lost their Irish Roots lamb I
need to inspire them with some good
oldfashioned ingredients lamb that could
be turned into 3 400 quids worth worth a
turnover how can you turn that into
something delicious yeah and sell it on
the [__] menu think of something for
chicken as well you know that let's see
what his vivid imagination can muster
not out of a cookbook they're off the
top of my
head
okay
ready yep right the chicken marinated in
Honey and whole green mustard served on
about a weltered
spinach go on I like that yeah yeah I do
like that you had a drink last night
last night yes yeah I didn't drink a
thing last night it tastes like [__]
yeah it tastes like [__] next DIC lamb
cooked in a tomato and Basel sauce and
just topped with Parmesan cheese put a
bit of chili just give it a little bit
of a bite the hood this is why I think
you destroy the majority of the stuff
you do because you put all these little
bits of [__] at the end that just blows
it I I don't think that's too bad mhm
almost reminds me of a STW like a like
an Irish Jew and if I came to Oscars I'd
love to see a real nice Irish STW if I
knew the chef was Irish bang you expect
I'd be over the [__] Moon that one's
workable but not bad okay thank you but
you can definitely do better yeah and
there's no time like the
present Irish family we put the cabbage
in I think we can do it quite sort of
rustic no okay Irish restaurant Irish
stew here we come shake shake shake so
we Dy them out a little bit cre a little
bit of fur around the outside almost
like a little bit like a fur jacket
that's what they do an island W wet we
in Island when they boil us CLS and
drain them welcome back you go back on
until they just start to fluff out why
the [__] are you telling me this yeah in
your own restaurant when you produce the
[__] you produced and now you've just
opened up and hit the nail on the head
you've fallen out of love with food
haven't you and a lot of people have
said that yeah I don't know why I no
reason why you've got to get it
back so
what does Mom
think I'm ashamed to say I'm Irish and I
couldn't make Irish do like this this is
lovely you you're Irish for [__] sake
you should be you know renowned in this
town for your Irish due walking around
like proud [__] I mean yeah and it's
it's simple it's basic it's
cheap yeah okay mother and son I
starting to see eye to eye now it's time
to get mature traine Chef Les up to
speed and did not to be a chef early on
in Life or no it never really never
really occurred to me I mean when I left
school it was just take what job I could
get at the time really
MoneyWise lear's had 21 jobs in 21 years
started cooking at 18 everything from
gas man to bingo caller give me a call
the eyes down here we go so it's uh on
the blue 4 and two blue 42 Two Fat
Ladies 88 all the Sev a pair of crutches
77 if he can cook as well as he can call
then job 22 could be the winning number
6 and two clicky do
62 read all the ones L
11 where the whistles oh they whistle of
course yeah thank you
whistles the chefs may be on side but if
Oscars is emptied midweek it doesn't
matter how much we improve the food how
much do you need to take a week to break
even to break even about three and a
half thousand M and what you taking on
average at a minute is two 2,000
relationships are frail and business is
down the pan but how long can you
continue surviving like this
oh I'm at uh at the end now I just I
can't carry on like this much longer
it's an eight I'm I am getting
worried my dream is just going down the
shoot where's the butcher C Mo's never
run a restaurant before and upstairs
establishments are the hardest to fill
so she got to get her business head on
your windows yeah they're [__]
amazing I've never seen such phenomenal
space in all my life you know that she's
been ignoring a tailor made marketing
Solution that's right on her doorstep
walking down here Craig he's totally
oblivious there's any restaurant hey
Chin's next door fine but bloody hell I
want to know what's going up in there
does any customers ever tell you that
they don't know where the resturant is
yeah didn't know you were here I think
you know what's coming what I want to do
is pull those beautiful big blinds down
and just stick Oscars
classic Irish cooking upstairs telephone
number and what I'd like to do is try to
come to some arrangement where you can
bring your family for little bite to eat
more will host the table and we can have
that bit of sort of working relationship
together that' be brilliant for us
brilliant for both of us yeah I'm just
trying to think of ways that we can have
as a bit of a marketing tour without
having to spend shedloads of money thank
you but's handshake solid as a rock
building a reciprocal relationship with
the butcher is key to Oscar's success
currently we're using upstairs your
fillet steak revive R the chicken
chicken the chicken and the ribs and the
ribs and is it local lamp local lamp
local produc yes thank you by making
full use of his local suppliers Lenin
and his customers will be getting a
better
deal fresh food on the day new menu it's
going to be a new menu on there so and
with Craig's name all over it yes I say
we'll put your name on our menu this is
where we get our meat so we need a good
discount how not you laugh I'm
serious he's getting the hang of this so
I'm going to push him even further I
want Lenin to buy lunch for 15 surprise
guests 30 quid on 30 quid on 30 quid so
what it's 2 pound ahead f for the love
come on please cheers if he can stick to
a budget he'll make more profit for the
restaurant how to the potatoes pound a
pound I'll give you 60 one cuz then you
can you know take taking a mod off them
he's definitely got the gift of the Gab
are you good at this yeah but can he
transfer some of that energy into the
kitchen are you
lazy yes I'd say that yes you are why
have you turned
lazy um I don't I I I can't I don't know
part because no one's driving you behind
and telling you what to do yes uhhuh
yeah maybe you've just hit the nail on
the head your mom is a weak lady I know
that so she's not going to be there
[__] caning you and [__] telling
you off no I get annoyed with her and
that's when the argument
starts they say never work with children
or
family today they're all here but I'm
keeping Lenin in the dark my little
surprise let me just say this is one
table right now Lenny you can't afford
to [__] up right yeah it won't be fued
up it better not be cuz his family are
his harshest critics especially his
younger brother Gilly I've been a few
times where I've come and I haven't been
overly impressed I'm not sure that
repeating the same dish uh constantly he
he can do at the same sort of level I
think that that is his biggest issue
this is a chance for you to show me that
you can cook and control something from
scratch and create something which is
not on the menu something completely
different and something a little bit
inspirational right excite me light my
[__] fire everything is fresh cooked
fresh all bought locally it's
[__] write me a [__] story line or
something cuz I have no idea what what
do you want me to say what I'm trying to
get out Lenny is some [__]
passion some [__] care and attention
and love for food Blow Me Away deep
fried local mushrooms stuffed with
mature cheddar cheese good slow roosted
pork finished with sage sounds nice the
dessert is fresh local strawberries
served on a bed of cream there you go
what was different than that it's all
that [__] you're telling me so hard
that's sounding
fantastic that's not so bad but the
pennies just dropped with me cuz that's
what you are lacking in
confidence a chef without confidence is
like a car without wheels and Lenin's
got to get in that driving
seat if he can woo the family with a
simple roast dinner that's half the
battle see this rock salt here I rub it
in there like that it takes out the
water out the fat what happens the
fat goes nice and CR up there you go the
other half of the battle is making full
use of his assistant Les you're an
important member of this team we need
you here and you got to feel a lot safer
when this guy's connected to you the
minute this guy is Not By Your Side your
mind's [__] you know that you
definitely need help maybe this will be
a turning point for lenon and with his
confidence boosted we can concentrate on
his cooking good
good hey hello 3 and a half minut
minutes for 15 main
courses yeah [__] well done do me a
favor and [__] off out there go
on it's time for
Lennon to meet his surprise
guest so how's he
fared this is
gorgeous this is absolutely
gorgeous what's the meat that's in with
the the cabbage onion black pepper but
he does have a connection with food
unfortunately he just lacks the
confidence that's the real sad thing
about this guy cooking for your family
is [__] difficult because they've
been criticizing him for a long time I
just wish he can actually do the same
now for his customers because if he gets
that right we've got a chance to get
this place back on the [__]
map it's Saturday night and Oscars is
fully booked want you to make it here a
favor Lenny's working with more as
expansive menu but to give them a
Fighting Chance there has to be a system
so that's nice and clear table S four
customers communication between front of
house and kitchen must be seamless
time's on there so we can really
concentrate on getting the food out and
there's no one's arguing then cuz you're
saying it's 25 minutes and he's saying
no bollocks it's only 10 minutes say
look it's on the ticket 7:00 now for me
the first ticket is absolutely crucial
we start off the evening with the first
ticket going out flying out hey there's
an indication that we're going to get
off to a really good start yeah right
let go wakey wakey I'm putting the
disasters of my first night down to
Lenny having a nerve steadying drink no
tonight I'll be watching him like a hawk
to see where he's going wrong T 11
covers two one soup one Reby an extra
portion of
chips
7:35 not bad and he's actually sounding
like a proper Chef can I go pleas yes
please thank you and that has been the
best eight covers I've seen go out of
this kitchen kit you know
that but after 40 minutes of faultless
control in the kitchen Lenny
mysteriously loses it big time Lon this
was cold and a bit tasteless I thought
we'd made good progress cooking for the
family Lon basically just apologize for
me how come we back at square
one what H is this
for kitchen's gone silent it's like
being in a church 1 2 3 4 5 six tickets
on board Les is W wandering around
looking for stuff to do you don't open
up and tell me what you're thinking I
can't help you no yeah could open up
it's pretty pants it's really bad I'm
really sorry about your delay between
our charm and the drink is about the
only thing holding it up
so I've never seen so much food come
back something fish is going on here
what's
uh what's in there I don't know I got
Cathy to do it for me I know tell me the
truth you said you're going to be honest
this morning R being in water and um V
in the bottom when you started off
service at 7:00 tonight yeah it was
going well you know that it's 9:00 and
they're starting to complain is that
because of that no that's the first one
that's come in the kitchen and that is
the truth but why did you tell me you
weren't going to
drink because I'm absolutely ni been
here all day and I just wanted one drink
so I got Catherine wrong I do apologize
for fire up
sorry
um service
um it's all becoming seriously
clear this is not just about Lenin's
lack of confidence you let me down
[__] big time halfast 8 inside that
[__] cup you sneaking vodka in and I
don't mind a beer after [__] service
I don't [__] care what you do after
service but in service from 7:00 to 11:
you [__] stay away from that and you
put your pressures on me you give me the
pressure and it's not just the kitchen
you're [__] you know that you're
screwing your M Restaurant it's gone
beyond food
now hat
[Music]
us we've hit rock bottom but Lenny's
proved to me he's got talent when he's
not drinking and he must care for his
mom and the business if he's here every
night for
nothing why does he drink he really gets
stressed and I often wonder am I putting
them under too much pressure you've got
to be very careful with that because
he's lost his motivation and he has lost
his Direction so you're the only person
that can turn that around you know that
every time you give him a drink in the
middle of the service you're pushing the
distruct button it's you that's going to
you know close the [__] door you
can't allow him another drink
yeah day three at Oscars and the
writing's on the
wall like many chefs Lenin finds it
difficult to cope with the stress of a
busy service unless he's had a drink
when you're in the middle of service
that's the last thing you need is a
[__] drink and I've seen my chefs try
to do it as well in the middle of
service by using alcohol to get them
through a very busy night and if you
haven't got your [__] wits about you
in the middle of service then you got no
chance they can be the most disastrous
the most dangerous place to be first
thing with Lenny is to take the pressure
away starting with his mom's deranged
bit of everything menu I was trying to
cover
everybody from 16
up and I made a pig zero of it can I
just say a menu that big even I wouldn't
attempt to cook you're putting a noose
around his neck because he's not capable
of doing it I think you're more capable
of doing four five starters four five
Mains four five desserts
[__] all else but for God's sake you're
both Irish so I want to have a bit of an
influence from there from the trout to
the potatoes to your Irish stew and make
it sort of become a
Hallmark I want to get lenon excited
about a new Irish theme menu let's get
this fish cake together show we garlic
butter and show him that food can give
him his kicks instead of the booze Comm
fish and hopefully they can taste the
difference between his cheap bought in
Cotton petta fish cake what you said
that chili sauce get it on there big boy
and my fresh homemade
alternative the first one that went in
your mouths was what bar homemade and
the second one that went in your mouth
was what that sh there you cut into it
what's the first thing the customer sees
Cola col fish yeah taals of salmon
smoked hadock little bit of mustard
that's
lovely that really was nice and this
place becomes renowned for the most
amazing homemade fish cakes Christ
almighty they're a good
size
go the menu starting to come together I
just hope I'm not putting too much
pressure on Lenny too soon are you
struggling today without a drink no I'm
not doing to that no I'm all right we're
cooking and the [__] [__] hits the
fan again and we're under pressure I
don't want you going out there no
guarantee you that the restaurant
relaunches in two days time but tonight
I'm trying to break Lenny in gently
we've got just 15 people booked and it's
a chance to try out some new specials
and push the Irish du and push all the
specials who's in charge of the dining
room I am you yeah I didn't feel that
the other night when I sat in here I
didn't feel like there's one person
actually controlling it I think there's
two or three things that are going wrong
in the service you really have to be
strong enough to tell them off about it
they'll respect you more one final thing
under no circumstances does anyone give
this man a drink in the middle of
service is that clear mom I no one that
objects yeah okay good put your foot
down so true put your foot down I'm sick
I put my foot down with him all your
restaurant yeah yes your son yeah you
[__] tell him yes we'll get a kick
good here we go the aim tonight is to
teach Lenny some control and discipline
we got 10 minutes before the first
customer comes you want to nip off a
quick cigarette do you mind you wouldn't
be telling me if you did hey yeah I do
but come back
this is the challenge you little
[__] okay every time you want to go
and leave this kitchen and disappear
outside for a cigarette you put a pound
in the Box every time I swear I put a
pound in the
Box here and that stays on
there no smoking or drinking for Lenny
no swearing for me one lamb medium to
well one chicken and ribs one portion of
chips time 8:15 you saw brought the
pastor out Les and leave Richard to tidy
up he can chop them for
you that's it now we're working like a
kitchen
guys there you go I don't know how well
Lenny's going to fare in this challenge
what's in the glass vodka
water [__] hell [__] too quick hold
on hold on have we started start getting
that full have we started it yes you did
[__] it add another one
oh right there you go he Les you happy
yeah let's be having
you nice and you check you check we sent
out three tables beautifully don't start
[__] up now
okay it's hard to break the habits of a
lifetime yeah H for star please L BL how
long are you how far are you away now 2
minutes talking over thank you and it's
8:00 so you must be ready for your next
cigarette fa cigarette you've gone
through a f in 2
minutes she that thing take two of us to
lift it so far so good no drinking no
smoking and the fresh fish cakes are
going down a storm nice they're nice and
light M all clean no come on seriously
yeah
Lovely One smoked salmon patty two
fishcakes cotton one cotton pan oh [__]
that I can't send out the decent fish
cakes with one of them cotton pan Jettas
and this is a big move for you and I'm
not trying to make you look [__]
stupid but I think you should go and
tell them that I don't think it's
something your mom should go and do
that's your [__]
kitchen yeah okay okay come back and
sell the fish
T where am I going the actual special
fish cakes are homemade today and
they're beautiful and I'll be honest the
other ones are frozen try them please
pride and
confidence right that is the
homade oh to
die and you spoken more year in the last
two hours than you did do for three days
last week yeah and it sounds
fantastic right and you sound in
control and you look bloody good thank
you Lennon's proved he can get through
on a quiet night without his usual
distractions I can smoke smoke some
fennel seeds
or here you go just try it try it try
this is therapy go on try
it there you go it's not bad
actually I'm now smoking asparagus and
it tastes [__]
delicious I enjoyed it it's nice to see
that standard of food going out and it's
nice to see it going nice and smooth and
not coming back so I'll sleep tonight
this time I'm sure I will right let's
get tidy down here we're making great
Headway in the kitchen now I can work a
mora I'm making it perfect for the
customers first problem finding the
place that looks fantastic oh that's
really lovely oh yes lovely lovely
you'll never never get a better
advertising space in that fresh home
cooking with an Irish flavor upstairs
that's lovely I'm glad you got the
flower box is done as well it looks like
there's something up there now hopefully
that should help get some more bums on
seats upstairs second problem to win
back Oscar's reputation by creating a
midweek bargain it's a small close-knit
town here in nwit so you've got to
install confidence back in the locals
and now is the time to turn it
around4 not too cheap you can make money
on4 pound for two courses if you can do
that Tuesday Wednesday Thursday with 30
customers a night 90 covers at 30 quid
ahead you know it's four and a half
th000 in the till no I like that and
everything's fresh next problem good
food at a bargain price isn't worth
anything without good service we have to
bond we have to Jael there's not enough
teamwork going on in here work with your
customers and work with your Chef stack
of the tickets coming through great
understanding and uh make sure we got
great
communication if they get it right then
they'll also help to take pressure off
the
kitchen one lamb medium to well one
chicken and ribs one portion of chips
time lenning gets off to a good start
but he seems a bit more stressed and
sounds less confident you're right Lenny
gone quiet on me he no
fine but evidently he wasn't later that
evening events took a terrible
turn
lenon collapsed he's been rushed to
hospital in an ambulance and I hope the
hell he's okay it was a [__]
[Music]
shock I need to know what's going on it
seems Lennon's drinking has aggravated
his health problems and I wish that I
got told the truth when we first met and
I felt he's put an amazing Brave face on
and he's he's stuck in there but you
know when I heard the problem last night
with the drink and his medical condition
and the problem with his liver you know
I was shocked on on the back of trying
to deal with that I thought Lon had told
you feel like you're not being honest
with me but I am a Gordon everything's
everything's hid from me I don't know
yeah I didn't know and it seems even
more isn't aware of the extent of his
problems Lenny
hello [__] H how are you not too yeah
yeah am I pleased to to see you how you
feeling better than last night anyway
[__] boy you scared me last night I'm
just amazed that you didn't want to sort
of share it with me early on because I I
I I would have rather known yeah it was
more embarrassment than nothing to be
embarrassed mate I just wish I knew when
we first met that you had that problem
and got nothing to be embarrassed about
I'm sorry [__] all to be embarrassed
about your health and your condition
makes far more important that restaurant
you know that
yeah can't go around like this I know
that and before he goes anywhere near a
kitchen yeah he's got to get himself
better and clearly start looking after
himself but before any of that takes
place the family have got to start
talking to each other so they can
[__] help
him using alcohol as a crutch in the
kitchen is a problem that can't be
ignored to better understand Lenin's
problems I've contacted pioneering Chef
Michael Quinn
thanks so much for coming over Michael
set up the Art Foundation to tackle the
industrywide problem of alcohol and drug
abuse after he himself was toppled by
the demon drink drinking we had the
perfect job for [__] sake the first
ever British chef to be crowned the chef
to cuisine at the Ritz hotel absolutely
when I left the RIT I was at the top of
the tree and alcohol just completely
took over my life yeah I went from the
RIT eventually to living on the the
street I slept on the bridges in
doorways you know I was in hospital with
liver failure I had the last rise from a
Catholic priest when when that that
close yeah why do chefs today think it's
part of a [__] rock and roll image to
drink our business as chefs is a very
tough uh it's a tough business the
immensely long hours we do the Heat and
also that that that you know you're
almost part of an sas Squad in in the
kitchen yeah it's that work hard play
hard we'll show the rest of the bastards
how good we are but one in 10 cross that
line and if you cross that line into
addiction into becoming an alcoholic you
can never go back to social drinking can
this guy continue to cook and deal with
a problem at the same time no no he
needs to be separated willpower doesn't
get you well in order to recover you
need to surrender and admit defeat and
that is the step forward to
Freedom Michael's an extreme case but
lenon needs to take a lesson from this
and nip his drinking Habit in the bud
before it's too
late we're all upset about lennin but
tonight sees the launch of our new menu
and The Show Must Go On everything on
this [__] menu here is fresh and the
sad thing is I wish Lenny was here to
cook it but I think what we do for
tonight's service is owe this one to him
yeah I think that sounds like the first
customers let's go with Lenin out of
action it's Bingo caller Les to the
rescue and he's nervous as hell right L
how are you doing not so bad not so bad
good you're sweating yeah yes good it's
a healthy sign when you sweat so you
stand on the hot planate you call out
and you tell me what you want doing
Gordon Rams is going to be your [__]
comei go EAS on him a little bit fragile
okay yeah run it through your mind first
yeah and bingo bingo eyes down for a
full house sex cover
three Pate two ribs one broth one
asparagus yes
Che gently nice and gently careful when
you putting the bow please yeah the idea
is not to Splash it everywhere yeah yeah
every time that's staying there Les you
just [__] up by letting it go Stone
Cold he's off to a shaky start but this
is his first time running a kitchen stop
stop stop come on lers [__] it what do
you want them to floss with the [__]
clim film come on go please give me a
little toss I'm sure you're good at
tossing come on watch those
eyebrows G shouts too
sh go one no dos go Mora's still not
leading her team in the dining room [__]
food doesn't get TI good food always
gets tips they need to be inspired work
the table charm
them come on
there happy yep good there you go cross
them off please table ey in the kitchen
things are looking up three fish cakes
two cabbage one pce three Mash yes is
fantastic it's absolutely [__]
amazing well done but the one thing
letting Les down is more as lack of
discipline front of house the last order
yeah one of the girls forgot to take the
main course out and that's what I said
earlier about how the DI really got to
[__] wake up a little bit it's not
funny sweetheart you're what I'm trying
to say we have got to get it together
end the story yeah quickly service the
numbers are really coming in for Les
tonight everybody okay outside
everybody's enjoying the food great are
coming back clean you're doing a good
job Le thank you very much I'm not a
great me teacher but this is brilliant
it's lovely I went for the ribey steak
which was coed superb food tonight was
gorgeous really really nice yeah he's
done a [__] good job everyone was
expecting him to sink and to crack and
to disappear and [__] off back to
college but uh he's done himself proud I
think more importantly he's done L proud
the fact that everything's gone out
brilliantly and smoothly you know and
the fact that spent all day preparing it
and from
fresh so why it I became a chef early
good feedback customers the last tip we
got was £1
£850 yeah fantastic you know some
mistakes tonight that they're really a
problem but they're so easily sorted so
that's just communication you that
you're not good at disciplining
staff is that what you think uh you show
You' proved to me I've never heard you
shout no heard you tell anyone off
because when this business closes they
will go off and look for a new
job
and if you're going to maximize in your
dream sweetheart and keep this place
open you so so so have to get on top
your business and your
money before I go I just want you all
for 30 seconds to close your eyes and
Les is just going to read off some
numbers give it to me Big Boy eyes down
looking Les's Den number
10 Two Fat Ladies 88 all the legs 11
anyway around 69 all credit to him
lear's pulled it off tonight fantastic
house but he's only a novice good night
and lenon needs rest and time to recover
before he even considers stepping foot
in a kitchen again there oh dear if Mo
is going to stand any chance of getting
Oscars back on track she needs to find a
new chef and
fast it's been a month since I spent a
week at Oscars and it was one hell of a
week what the hell was this for the food
was so bad the customers came once but
never returned somebody having laughing
the head chef lacked respect for the
place I'd say get [__] his mom the
owner was at a Wit's End I just I can't
carry on like this much longer Lennon
smoked and drank on the job been here
all day and I just wanted one drink but
we work through
it we sent out three tables beautifully
don't start [__] up now and the new
menu was looking great food tonight was
gorgeous really really nice but Lennon
wasn't he collapsed he's been rushed to
hospital in an ambulance and I hope the
hell he's
okay after a break hi guys Lennon's back
in the kitchen and I'm here to find out
how he's doing thank you we got some
color on your face you look Brown you
look feel a lot better now yeah drink
wise are you seeing someone that's yeah
I am actually I've been to my doctor and
I've been everything sorted out couple
of bad days here and there but
um the majority good most important
thing you do something about it you know
that cuz that's not fair on you and
that's not fair in mom and it's not fair
on the restaurant when are you having a
drink after service before service what
are you doing before um anytime now
99.9 after service possibly sometimes
don't even bother I just go home and get
on your bed I'll sit right now bit of
menus and just messing about at home
really are you eating properly oh God
yeah I'm eating like I can't stop eating
at the moment well you're not exactly
[__] fat are you Len turn around let
me show POA tummy that's what you call a
[__] triplet in there big boy he's
[__] eating properly hello Gordon how
are you I'm all right thank you good to
see you how are much not too bad yes yes
um how's business um well me quiet you
and AG have coming on now uh-huh midweek
it's getting better more importantly
Lennon is he up to the job of actually
running it
fulltime I'm a
I'm afic not certain no no no oh it's
all right but it's
it's drinking and uh kitchens and stoves
don't go together do they no lethal
combination Mor is Keen to take the
burden away from Lennon she's lined up a
potential new head chef but Lennon's not
happy about it I mean I've watched my
own restaurant um since I was a child I
wanted to be my dad uhhuh um
and now that it's
here I do have that fear that it's going
to be taken away from me no one's
getting rid of I understand what you're
saying yeah we're trying to think of a
way forward so we can um benefit keep
this place alive and and and and keep
your mom's dream and her ambition you
cannot continue like this you know that
it's going to kill you and a new Chef I
think is a breath of fresh air you so
can we kiss and make up and let's meet
this [__] chef
huh thank
you I
[Music]
love Mark Warrington is a fully trained
chef with an impressive CV oven's on but
can he cook come with anything you wish
one dish is fine
[Music]
yeah come through and well it looks a
little bit more [__] chinesey than it
does to Irish to me the fish is but the
rest of it but the potatoes are Irish
the fishes cook nice Naked Fish is L
yeah it was quite interesting seeing you
guys bonding
there and good work Mark no problem all
problem L Lon and me basically we can
bounce ideas off one another what seeing
in the kitchen looks like we found our
Man Mark starts his new job at Oscars
next
week but tonight is Lennon's chance to
shine I can't [__] do anything in
there if you don't come and talk to me
everything that you know is fresh it's
got to go out but of a surprise you
tonight I haven't told any of you oh B
what's coming now I've got 10 very
important customers coming it's the 10
customers that are absolutely fuming the
first night I had dinner here big
[__] night now on top of that they're
going to be presented with this this an
Oscar's Restaurant loyalty card and it's
to inspire them to return to the
restaurant and on their sixth visit
they'll come as our guests look out for
them yeah this evening MO is hosting an
Irish night if it's going to run
smoothly The Waitresses must be Keen as
well as green um are you in control yes
yeah cuz remember last time I wasn't
that impressed with the service you know
that and tonight I'm going to be all
over the service you know that like a
rash yeah who's kitchen's this mine do
you want me to stand back yes if you
don't mind and not interfere yeah so
I'll stand back all right I stand yeah
what done about [__]
dancing I can moonwalk but I can't
[__] dance I've seen nothing got to
be honest you look like a r
TR the menu of Irish Jew and pork and
Guinness is exactly right for Oscar's
new Irish
theme first order Patty soup and the
garlic mushrooms um two fish cake two
veg three
potatoes also a good start yeah
yep and the restaurant's full so the
waitresses have got to give it their
best just slow the girls down a little
bit get them walking a little bit
gracefully like ladies yeah not like
baby
elephants Lennon's food seems to be
hitting the spot 100 times better by a
mile I've got my loyalty card and I I
will come I will come back from my Pella
with crabsticks to what I've had tonight
big miles of high really is the place
are consistently coming back empty but I
thought Bingo caller Les might have
shown a bit more pizar Les you're a big
softy you know that push him out the way
take some pressure off him and be strong
big softies don't make good Cooks I
don't want to [__] hear that you've
turned into a [__] dinner lady yeah
we working for [__] Jamie Oliver
yes it's been a good night for lennin
but I'm pleased he's got a chef to help
him
[Music]
through maybe more as Irish dream will
come true after
[Music]
all do that
done
[Applause]
Fant one last thing 15 Stone chefs with
size 14 ft don't dance dance I'm telling
you I can't
dancece can't dance I can't I'm not
going to [__]
dance oh no no no babe I'm babe I can't
dance it doesn't
matter coming just a
quick promise you now H I cannot
[Music]
dance I think it'll lead him to
it how many people does it take to run a
small Seaside hotel and restaurant I've
never seen so many [__] managers
supervisors head receptionists and Sue
chefs I'm absolutely God smacked in this
week's nightmares I check into a real
life Faulty Towers to find out thank you
got it looks like something out a poor
movie I call physically taste everything
within the kitchen or I'll end up like a
a big air balloon I would have
thought I spok to the resturant manager
yes I've spoken to the F beverage
manager I'm now talking to the general
manager [__] wake up with you
yeah wake
[Music]
up the sanate hotel is perched on a
gorgeous stretch of the Kent
Coast it's 24 mil from France but a
million miles from being a good hotel
and
restaurant the Sate Hotel
[Music]
what a great
spot it's got 15 rooms and a covered AA
rosette for its food and I'm checking in
first test of any hotel is the reception
always a great sign of How It's
run you can smell
itol hello thank you
sorry you on the phone yeah is it urgent
no I'll tell him that I'm going tell him
as a customer sorry see I'll see you
byee we have room number four thank
you 3 years ago Lois and Peter Hamilton
Slade pulled their life savings and
bought the
sandgate at the moment this place is
losing around two grand a week so Peter
has had to keep his engineering job
while Lois runs the hotel and
restaurant you've obviously run
restaurants before no uh no never never
or small guest houses then no never
never this is our first first effort
this is the restaurant oh it's very
small isn't it yes very small Lois has
gone from selling perfum at Gatwick
Airport to managing this small boutique
hotel by the Sea and the food comes up
through the stairs no it comes through
here okay okay dumb waiter yeah dumb
waiter a husband and wife team running a
hotel and a dumb
waiter [__] all the restaurant yeah
to the kitchen restaurant to the kitchen
and that must be a nightmare there it
seems to work very well does it yeah
extraordinarily it's not just one
restaurant there's also a Terrace
barbecue a bar and Ken's first Japanese
restaurant in the basement it's a
strange mix but they do have one thing
in common no
customers how long can it survive if we
don't have a very good summer or I don't
think we will get through the winter and
if the [__] hits the fan and that
doesn't take place and we have a crap
summer MH um what do you
lose probably quar of a
million sometimes we've had comments
that the food is inconsistent I I think
that is a lot of the case when Stuart's
not here Stuart's the head chef head
chef the Japanese Chef where's he from
it's the same Chef the same same one the
same Chef we haven't got a Japanese chef
but youve got a Japanese restaurant yes
hello how are you very well thanks and
Stuart Stuart 38 from North umberland
he's been here for 6 months it's his
first head Chef's job but since he's got
here he started hearing voices
thank you you do thank you guys well my
little system of communication is it
like that all night yeah how did you
concentrate with that try and ignore it
as much as possible [__] hell not
driving around the bch yeah do order for
Table
9 oh hello me n yeah hello can you [__]
off and do some work four restaurants
168 dishes and one kitchen
time to taste the food okay thank you
and there are theal the specials yes
that's the and the alakat can a look at
the Japanese menu as well please of
course you can thank you four in tonight
Saturday
night so just to let you know we don't
actually serve Japanese in this
restaurant just just to right and so
I'll go downstairs my stter and come
back here for our main
course um I need to see the the F for
the Mage manager see what I can do for
you food B's manager
[Music]
yes I mean what a way of pissing
customers off are you the food and
beverage and sorry first name Kevin
Kevin so you really want me to go
downstairs and have my Sushi there
that's what I've been told by the
general manager and who's that it's
kirst kirst let me have a word with
kirst thank you very
much [__]
extraordinary I've spoken to the restant
manager yes I've spoken to the food B
manager I'm now talking to the general
manager um have you ever watched saly
tows yes yeah
Japanese we've got three managers two
waitresses but only four customers the
numbers just don't add
[Music]
up the rice is hard what a [__] up but
it's not the only one next chicken from
the alart
menu
thank you God it looks like something
out poor
movie it's enough to make your eyes
water excuse me waitress I'm missing my
Bonet
um it doesn't taste of chicken it tastes
of tomato it's like sundried tomatoes
running through it but they're so so
strong not for
[Music]
me the Macky rolls who made them I
did and how old are you 18 18 so you
don't taste anything that this
18-year-old cook I can't physically
taste everything within the kitchen or
I'll end up like a a big air balloon I
would have thought I like
the I I like I like to to obviously
taste as much as I can a head chef who
doesn't taste his food is asking for
trouble I've never seen anyone cut it
before is the only way to maintain
control and keep up
standards plenty time I think that the
race is underdone thank you that's all
it's really important for you and I to
obviously stand the level like I said
you can you can see I'm not Japanese
clearly I'm not trying to dig a hole and
try and Escape for for Yushi that was
uh I've still got in my
[Music]
teeth
Stuart doesn't want to cook Japanese
food the people of sang don't want to
eat Japanese food so why in their hell
have they got a Japanese restaurant this
place doesn't know what it's doing and
that's clearly down to one thing bad
management Lois has got more managers
than the rits but I can't work out who's
running this place and I got a sneaky
feeling no one else can
either the business is in danger of
closing I don't think you actually know
how dire the situation is the amount of
management and the amount of staff in
such a small place I've never seen in my
entire life you know that I've never
been so confused with supervisors and
managers and head receptionists you're
running this hotel like a 350 bedroom
five-star Deluxe and the most important
war is no one seems to be controlling it
I've come up with an exercise to try and
find out who is in
charge drop this Stone in the bucket of
the person you think is in control of
the sandgate hotel the whole
organization the whole
organization oh dear he's gone past all
the managers and ignored
Lois
okay next Luca the restaurant
manager surely he must
know
he just picked the head
receptionist next up is Kevin the food
and beverage manager have most done can
you have more Stones everybody should be
running it that's the point everybody
should be running it okay it should be
run as a group that's what I'm trying to
get through now that's the problem
everybody is running it and there's no
one controlling it okay the voice on the
top y thank you
and you hit the nail on the head that's
what's exactly [__] happening
everybody's trying to run it and they're
not doing their own
jobs so interesting we're all here now
and there's five of you that have got
stones in your buckets so already
there's a conflicting message if this
business is to survive Lois needs to
take command of
it she's got a few stones but she's got
no bollocks if she doesn't grow a pair
the hotel is going to be washed
up
[Music]
the sang hotel in Kent has lost £33,000
in the first four months of this year
but while Rome Burns Lois and Peter the
owners seem determined to eat drink and
be merry
meal after meal after
meal my brief when I started was it's
run like L and Peter's living room and
that's how they wanted it that's
basically what I was told what
run it as if it's their Lounge basically
[__] running a hotel and restaurant is
not the same as eating and drinking in
one Lois and Peter bought a dream now
they need to wake up to the fact that
it's a business not a second
home day three at sangate towers and a
chance to see the ter Barbie [__]
hell hardly a day for a [__] barbecue
I feel like I'm a [__] car boot sale
steuart's work some good kitchens in his
career but they get him to set up a
portable Barbie it's heartbreaking you
don't get any customers today sake SI
that [__] thing surely they can't
make their headchef suffer anymore like
kitchen kitchen are you
there are we all
set H give us uh oh 4 minutes on a bison
garnish please
where's that to K this place is like a
jigsaw but none of the pieces fit
strange setup so he's out there on the
barbecue and you're left to run the
kitchen [__] H you're 20 years of age
you're 18 years of age I mean how come
you got all that
responsibility and what happens when
it's
busy
[__] who would put someone who's clearly
a good Chef in charge of a barbecue time
to find out from the manager but which
one Kirsty how are you the general
manager is Lois's
daughter-in-law before coming to Britain
she worked in restaurants in her native
New Zealand the barbecue how would you
describe
that um my aim was for a kiwi barbecue I
thought that that sort of teritorial
kiwi Beach life something like that but
sweetheart we're not in [__] ockland
we're in
sangate the lack of focus in this place
is astounding Lois hasn't even got her
Flagship fine dining restaurant under
control
the majority of the
complaints that come through are
normally on your day off have you ever
eaten in the restaurant no cuz if the
complaints are going on when you're not
here you've got to see what they're
serving in the dining room so you can
really do something about it properly
yeah and identify it are we too
complicated is the menu too big are they
in experien do we need to simplify it
what then what do I need to do as a head
chef you're the food bage manager have
you ever eaten up here yeah how can you
relate to your customer experience if
you're not experiencing at the same time
go upstairs order y I think you'll find
something very interesting going on
there
y Kirsty hasn't worked at the sharp end
of the business for about 8 months so
today she's going to
waitress don't know what's on and what's
off but I'm sure you do stud number two
in the kitchen is 21-year-old Johnny
hello so what's going first Johnny I'm
going to send this SP first and then the
starters the BR just gone up for the two
but I can't find anyone to take it out
of the lift
yet is it always like this yeah Johnny
runs the kitchen two days a week when
Stuart's off this is my chance to see
how he CES come on guys that's 10
minutes those place to be there we're
[__] around with the gar they're a
young team to be cooking such elaborate
food and just to add to it Johnny they
ordered it over 1 hour ago yeah yeah
let's get it out guys come
on
careful I'm not going to you to send
them this is really important for you
you know that from a professional point
of view cuz you've got to go all the way
up to the top in this [__] industry
not serving [__] like that big boy and
all you're doing by serving that [__] is
hey destroying the place and that's just
on a [__]
burger and I know you can do better than
that you know that I Know I Can Do
Better there you go so [__] do it
yeah there are only nine customers in
for lunch but it's well over an hour
before Stuart and Kevin get their
mains that
Co
Bell's working up here did you get that
I can my
start unfortunately Kevin and Stewart
aren't the only unhappy customers Johnny
T [__] off they've gone that's the
table that had no starters went straight
to the main courses where's the ticket
gone in the bin why have you put it in
the bin I didn't but that's where ended
up [__] wake up will
yeah wake up
this is one of the worst lunch Services
I've ever seen Johnny's tried his best
but the real culprit is
clear it's Stuart's food ready it's just
far too
complicated certainly been
educational to say the least STS had a
shock upstairs
too I never thought I would be certain
bar I actually walked out you walked out
yeah [__] why didn't you walk out cuz
I seen someone else eating my desserts
but I'd been waiting for 35 minutes a
head chef walking out of his own
restaurant this place has sunk about as
low as it can
go
morning how are
[Music]
you Stuart's seen firsthand what's wrong
upstairs I think the best people tell
him what's wrong downstairs say are his
own Brigade but I think the young chefs
like this soft-hearted Jordie so much
they've been too afraid to pipe up in
case they hurt his feelings it's time
they told their boss a few home truths
so whoever catches the bass today as you
catch that bass you turn around openly
and tell Stuart something you got a lot
to say haven't you what happens if I
catch
you who can I cry
to [__] me big
boy here we go come on
Daddy Round of
Applause more important of what we got
to say all right let do quickly CU
Luke's in you got lovely but there's too
much of
it thank
you well done Luke what have you got to
tell Chef I just think that the menu's
nice and that there's just I think
there's too many garnishes ready for the
dishes no problem that thanks what
telling us that's that's what old it is
really at 38 Stuart's old to have just
got his first head check job I think
he's desperate to impress if we simplify
it I think we can get the taste a lot
better and we can get the stuff looking
so much better instead of having to try
and rush it out all the time I just
don't like the service being manic cuz I
know that I can do better myself and I
know the rest of us
can great they're starting to enjoy
themselves teen Spirits vital to a good
kitchen
ni yeah hold on Johnny two of the
biggest fish so far [__] the only one
pissed off is me 4 hours on the English
Channel and I didn't catch a
thing sangate is twinned with sonat a
French Town 24 mil across the
channel but instead of seeking
inspiration from France Lois and ciry
have got the chefs cooking food from New
Zealand and Japan 6,000 miles
[Music]
away my plan is to bring them home see
bass you're not going to get any better
any fresher quality ingredients than
that it's on your doorstep that's what I
want you to take advantage of Stuart
Seabass dish on the alakat menu has 15
ingredients which is why the boys
struggle so much with it I'm going to
show them the simpler version with just
five ingredients and then just let the
knife do the work that's true
in back on the stove I think what I'm
trying to do is just show you how easy
it can but one person can do this narrow
down the complexity of it and it can be
done within 3 or 4 minutes you know that
yeah SE
bass and the dish is going to be just as
exciting with less on there because
we're concentrating on the sea bass
being hot the dish being less complex
and flavor
Lois has been guilty of putting
unrealistic demands on Stuart no chef
with a small team can cook 168 dishes
really well we've got to convince her
and Peter that less is more absolutely
amazing superb the Seabass has won them
over but there's bad news we sadly had a
letter this morning to say that we've
lost our AA rosette y have you got the
letter with you I sorry it was for the
food guide
right one AA rosette is awarded for food
cooked with care and
skill but forced to cook for four
restaurants Stewart has slipped below
that
standard this a kicking the bollocks for
any chef there's no two ways about that
but in a way it's a clean start we turn
the page we make it less complex and we
go
again
[Music]
[__]
H oh
[Music]
dear we haven't got long to turn this
place around and I'm worried I don't
know if The Big Friendly Giant will be
able to pick himself up from this
one bad news that just lost the RO
up what was
that it away
I'm
gutted what can we do a kick in the
teeth let a it's a bullet to the
heart if Lois isn't careful it won't
just be steuart's Professional Pride
down the pan less is more on the plate
and in the hotel we need to simplify
everything so what's left can sparkle
fck out
the weakest link is the Japanese
restaurant how's it goingo Sayo up and
down up and down it's costing more to
staff than it's making last week it took
just
£290 and I'm personally worried about it
and what about
you that's uh to fa uhhuh I think we're
in love with the idea more than we are
with the success of the business and my
idea is to close it mhm and to stop
Heming money what would you suggest we
did with it here I think you got a
perfect room for a private dining um an
overspill from the restaurant that's a
good idea it's a fantastic idea and I
think whether he's got the bollocks to
tell you or not I'm going to tell you
he's not very comfortable cooking it
he's not a [__] Japanese Chef he's a
[Music]
Jordan I put the food back on the road
to recovery and got rid of that stupid
Japanese but front of house is still a
shambles hello when when did your book
uh when we arrived this evening oh okay
no problems right I do have some space
for you okay but I don't have you on my
list I'm sorry sorting out the chaotic
customer service is too much even for me
would you like to take a
seat basil thought he wouldn't like it
but what this place needs is a Frenchman
[__] me am I happy to see you are you
well I'm very well yeah I'd like to
introduce you to Jean Baptist he M to
from clares Jean Baptist is in charge of
70 waiters if there's anyone who can
help Los organize the restaurant it's
him um right let's have a look at the um
wait he'll take control upstairs one I
help Stuart keep things chip shaped
downstairs where the food comes up from
the kitchen and to the restaurant so the
customers going to hear the waitresses
talking the restaurant manager talking
and the buzzer also there you go goes
right through the dining
room there you go that when the first or
any of
the within minutes of arriving Jean
Baptist B the intercom system from now
on the waiters will have to go
downstairs and talk to the chefs face to
face like to come hello how are you even
the basics aren't looked after here Luca
the restaurant manager hasn't got enough
cold water for lunch yeah because you're
going to run out of water quickly my
friend you got two B of water yeah but
what I would do I would Tess with ice a
lemon and what about you don't want any
rce and lemon that's warm unfortunately
unfort dis you know un how you going to
do that Luka Luka those glasses they're
fing dirty look at
that hey this is what we need to change
Luka it's it's it's we have to be
customer orientated okay front of house
have had absolutely no leadership or
quality control from Lois of course fa
that I take the menu you are the owner
okay you got the restaurant manager got
some water to bring the men okay while
you're here you're here to be here
facing the customers welcome okay
welcome home you know this is exactly
what I wanted to do Welcome Home the
first check is
in you're not too hard clear face to-
face communication like this should cut
out all the wrong orders and
misunderstandings okay that wasn't was
it what's it like having the tickets in
the kitchen now in your
hands on control you feel in control I
can spend a little bit more time coping
which is what I'm best at that's [__]
banned guys look hello
yeah no one touches that [__] thing
okay you need to pick up the bread and
the butter now so who's going to do it
it's nuts K me who's going to do it
him they working here so what do you
mean walk in here the staff is coming in
like that a member of Staff ignoring
Lois and heading for the bar and she
hasn't battered an eyelid what's going
on you're the faking owner not even say
hello to you can you believe
that
it's it's a fing nightmare it's it's
it's a bad organization it's lack of
communication lack of team team spirit
team leader it's nobody knows what
they're doing um the the waiter is
managing the the owner the owner is
doesn't know what she's doing um it's
it's a freaking mess it's
mess Jean Baptist has helped reorganize
the restaurant but he's also uncovered
the ultimate symptom of everything
that's wrong with Lois's
business
staff are allowed to drink on the
premises I need to get to the bottom of
this they spend a lot of money in they
spend over £2,000 a month in the bar
£2,000 a month [__] me 500 quid a week
on staff drinks that's what they spend
have you become dependent on that
possibly I guess to a degree we sat down
and looked at you know how much we were
earning off of them at the the end of
the day you know it reduces the celery
bill it's even worse than I
thought because how on Earth are you
going to get the message across when
you're treading on eggshells to not
upset them because they're going to be
spending £2,000 a month in the bar
[__] hell I've never heard anything
so pathetic in all my life everyone's
taking the piss and maybe there is an
advantage having too many staff because
they're spending £2,000 a month in the
[__] bar drinking and clearly that's
keeping the business
[Music]
afloat the sang hotel in Kent is in
serious trouble it's got a great
location and a great chef but I know no
who hasn't got a clue how to run her
business I'm in the midst of trying to
rescue it [__] wake up will you
you wake up in just 2 days time we're
relaunching the restaurant with a French
flavor we're holding an oy eting
competition against a French team from
SAS but I've discovered that owner Lois
and her manager Kirsty are getting the
basics wrong they allow their staff to
use the bar as a common room which is a
sure far way to drive your customers
away it is our fault we have done it
wrong I do I can absolutely see it that
we have done it wrong cuz it's building
up it's getting more and more familiar
they're more and more drinking G and
sometimes people there so many St the C
customers can't get to the bar the staff
are spending over 24 Grand a year on
booze and [__] but I'm putting a stop to
it now once you've finished your shift
I'm afraid you cannot come and sit in
the bar and drink now that has huge
implications in this
company I think you all know that that
is
massive this business is not run for
staff and the owners no longer depend on
you guys putting money in behind the bar
and secondly you got no idea of the
conflicting messages it's sending to the
customers and you can't serve a member
of the public and then go and sit in the
same bar and drink with them it's not
good never seen it in my entire life and
it's got to stop this is not a drinking
hole this is not a socializing Gaff can
I just ask whether when you say stuff
allowed to drink does that mean their
day is off as well why does anyone want
to come here on their day off let me
tell you why because it's too [__]
easy let's go down the sandgate let's
sit there and get bladed let's sit on
the Terrace let's sit it's too too comfy
haven't you got homes to go to it's just
become too convenient I think we can all
agree that then when there's asses to be
kicked the next day and disciplinary to
take place no one wants to listen to the
owners or ciry because we've sort of had
a chat and had a drink over it and
nothing's got done if this place has got
any hope of surviving and going from
strength to strength to identify the
customers are more important the staff
that has to stop cheers thank let's get
back to work we're going to have to be
very careful as well because you know
there is a tendency to come and here and
you know L and Peter meet up in here at
the end of the day and you know have a
drink together we I guess to a degree
we're going to have to leave by example
at last someone's talking about leading
it's not Lois but I think we're getting
somewhere I'm going to have to have a
cigarette but I'm still worried about
Stewart since he lost the AA Ros that
his morale has hit rock
bottom to have any chance of pulling off
the relaunch I need the Jordy giant back
from the Dark Side regarding the
Accolade you [__] get it back and and
get it back properly without trying to
cook 168 dishes get it back cook in a
menu that you can
control why' you shout so much my point
[__] now I'm going to help him devise
a new menu that's right for a Seaside
Hotel focusing on fresh fish with a
French twist if I came to sit in the bar
or even sit in the restant here I'd love
a bowl of Mo FR here I'd love a platter
freed the a I'd dive for it know why cuz
it could relate to the food because
there's the [__] sea oh it's ideal
like you say I mean all you know and and
pricewise as well yeah uh ideally
located to to buy fresh fish for
basically next to
nothing oh
just I'm waiting to see this whole
kitchen just was with a smell of bully
Bas yeah the frogs will be swimming
across that channel to get in here yeah
what about a nice big Sumptuous Rich
pear tatan pears from Kent bring a
little bit of [__] England meets
France France meets
England where's the sugar there right oh
Johnny good smell out there the caman
seeds that's
lovely
okay
M as well as a new menu we also need new
customers so Saga the biggest employer
in town with nearly a thousand workers
just around the corner from the
restaurant is Saga look armed with two
dozen oysters we've come to turn them on
to fresh
seafood they're very nice delicious
anything happening
downstairs you're tummy feeling sort of
warm and
sexy all the produce is local fish that
you can see from the s get to Hotel the
same with the oysters the crab chips
it's good to start talking about other
things in the menu the idea of just
getting them to sort of up to speed with
the oysters is for you then to sort of
let them know about everything else
going on yeah it's essential the
restaurant attracts locals who are still
around when the tourists go home these
are the people who will keep the
business afloat in the winter can I ask
a question how's your sex life one
perfect let me get you some
oysters straight down I said nice lovely
and there's an added bonus for
you they've got the most amazing
bedrooms upstairs if things are going to
plan word of mouth is the best publicity
you can get in the restaurant trade and
hopefully we've just set a, tongues
wagon tun
large menu of two
sizes Lois's front of house team are
still flapping she treats him like like
her extended family and seems afraid to
discipline them it's got to change and
I've been wrecking my brains out all
[__] week on how Lois and get really
strong with her staff and I've got a
good
idea [__] you
now you know just one of them one of
them not will [__]
10 no that's going to be terrible you
greasy
[__] lovely assertiveness training
Chef style the photos really
tell him exactly what you think of him
Luca I think you're an extremely nice
person and you're an asset to the place
dear she's more like M than maton like I
own it you have got to have respect for
me and I don't think you have yeah I
think with him you've got to get really
to the point so I'm not going to put
that there Luca every time I want
something you do it do as you're told or
look for a new [__]
job right now you don't have to say [__]
him it's a chef's thing far away Luca
it's time that you learn I cannot put up
with you interrupting me all the time
and not doing what I ask you you work
for me I do not work for you good much
better Chef every time I speak to you
you interrupt me it's absolutely Gob
smacking and it's incredibly Bad Manners
Kevin you'll come steaming in and
interrupt and start talking over over
the top of me do not do it now we're
getting somewhere I need respect from
everybody listen to what I'm telling you
and for Christ sake get on with it good
do you feel any better yeah it's lovely
isn't it do
you now what you do for real yep yeah
real thing the real thing we have a
quick word with LCA yeah tell him what
you want tell him what you need and tell
him how important this is to you and how
he does his talk yes yeah do you want me
to do it for you no let's
go absolutely
[Music]
with when I said to you last night that
Cynthia was to do the ladies in the bar
immediately you said to me Cynthia
mustn't do the ladies in the B of if
it's like me and Kevin coordinating the
function then you come in breaking in
with instructions going to be too many
people giv instruction that's what I'm
here to do I have to control it Luca in
a nutshell just do as she says sure and
if you got an issue with it talk to her
after service but in the middle of
service do as she says yeah okay I must
must be heard and take a notice off okay
good thank you nice one thank
you Lois has finally discovered her
inner chef and not a moment too
[Music]
soon do as I say end the
story in a few hours time we relaunched
the restaurant
and this menu yeah is clear
straightforward it can be eaten in the
restaurant it can be eaten on the
Terrace and it can be eaten in the
bar 60 of the area's most influential
people are coming for lunch so the chefs
will need to pull together like a team
I've got here for you guys the most
amazing jackets spotless guess what
we're going to do before we put those
jackets
on go on all right we going in the we're
going in the SE
exactly we're going to have a quick dip
before lunch who's up for
it come on you can all do in the [__]
[Music]
showers here we
go y
y
done with great Seafood on the menu the
first to arrive naturally enough are the
French welcome to the Sate
Hotel this is the team that the chefs
are taking on in the Oyster shocking
competition after lunch and it looks
like they've all been in training so
this is sorry Louis excuse me sh one
tuna large portion yeah chef yeah one
cocko van with the first orders in the
kitchen swings into
action that looks beautiful very nice
think it's the Hat it's all in the Hat
yeah good what a transformation from a
week ago the food simple the chefs are
calm collected and working as a
[Music]
team but for Lois and her waiters
upstairs it's a different story
exuse it's going
pearshaped
I've never seen them so far the [__]
upstairs you know that all my guys have
came in early they crack a dawn we had
time to go for a swim we had time to go
for a swim before service but I tell you
what I tell I know who's swimming now
huh I think we're about to
sing I need to find out what's happening
and stop the
rot another wrong order means more work
for the chefs we got to cook the salmon
again though haven't we yeah it's only a
table two if it's a table of six I can
understand but what one table of two's
order wrong boy come on I know it was
the noise let's go oh come
on where is it glass everywhere let me
just start the table
again and to top it all the general
manager is having a drink on the Terrace
and Lois hasn't stopped her what is
going on it's 130 coming up um just out
of Interest why can't Cy jump in and
give us a hand it's such a big day no
disrespect having drinks with her Maids
you know a day like today what kind of
message is that
serving can you help out no one's taking
care of the Terrace one table's already
left because it wouldn't have their
order taken we just need General help
I'll just find out from L where she
wants me it's an absolute Nightmare and
these poor men out here still waiting
for their main to go and Chase
that everyone should be hands on [__]
deck now you know that yeah a week ago
it was pandemonium down here and [__]
all happening upstairs now it's
pandemonium upstairs and everything
happening here you know that two oysters
natural one oysters deep fried two
prawns Lois is finally getting control
front of house she's cracking the whip
with her staff and getting them working
like a
team but the first time in a week the
customers being put first
formid Absolut formid what an
[Laughter]
improvement it's very nice to see more
fish on the menual particular as well
near to the Sea I'm enjoying it very
much I love more Mar here on both sides
of the
channel that is only what is left
because come on being French we have t
out of it feel like a
millionaire Stuart and the chefs have
pulled it off thanks to these guys as
well now they fac the French team in the
oyster eating
competition special events that get the
restaurant noticed and talked about are
a great way to bring in more custom
welcome to the first ever sandate versus
sonat oyster shocking
[Music]
competition which within 5 minutes
you're going to have to open and eat as
many oysters as
possible if Lois and Peter can make this
an annual competition it will help
improve Anglo relations and do their
restant a power of Good Into The Bargain
one minute to
go 3 2 1
Stop 28 for the
[Music]
fridge all excuse me please and Peter
for the Sate English how many please we
only did 7
to6
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus she's trying to drag me back to
[Applause]
[Music]
France
[Applause]
today's been a great launch pad for the
restaurant now it's up to Lois to take
the place forward and run it like a
business not like a living room stay on
top of them yeah I saw it a week ago
thinking God you know you may own the
place but you're not running it yeah
you've got to run it and own it there a
big difference there is yeah and don't
fall in love with it cuz it's a job
correct yeah you got to keep at them and
on them and at them and on them and at
them that but for my money Stuart's the
hero when he lost his rosette earlier
this week I thought I'd lost him but all
credit to him he's pulled it round you
deserve to make it yours yeah stick to
what you know you can do properly and
stand firm on that one hey you still
look like Jimmy now was it the nose or
the accent or the accent the accent can
you sing yeah give a song Wild beer and
Spirits all attack
they've got 6 weeks until I come back I
hope they're still singing
then's on my
mind at the beginning of the summer I
spent a week at the sangate hotel it
looks like a poor
movie it couldn't work out if it was a
comedy or a tragedy 4 minutes on a b and
garnish please I simplified the food got
the owner to run the place like a
business I must
must be heard and taken nce off okay
made a splash at the
relaunch 6 weeks later I'm
back good
morning how are
you how are you I'm very well thank you
Lois the helm that's a good sign hello
Gordon are you well I'm well thanks yes
here's one I caught earlier present for
shirt good to see you both I'm sure
it'll be delighted um is he downstairs
yep he is [__] what you mean [__]
hell that's not a nice reception very
well than you how are you very well huh
how are you we put that in the fridge
and we'll have a uh we'll have a chat
about that later the last time I was
here the staff was spending two grand a
month in the bar and before I banned it
Stewart was one of the worst offenders
what have you been spending your money
on per month that you're not spending
upstairs in the bar decided to go out
there and have a little beab man no yeah
that's fantastic news yeah to be
spending too much time with
home see what happens that's great news
in the kitchen he's got a new system to
tell the waiters upstairs when the food
is ready explain it to me it's a
vibrating system a vibrating system so
if it's uh we at number one yeah well
then press the number one button gives
them a little tickle all the waiters are
working with vibrators [__] hell
that's fantastic ftic yeah huh and any
waiters need more sort of jigs than any
of that yeah yeah I mean if they don't
if it doesn't come out I just give them
all a tickle
like one thing very interesting that um
the customers that come now yes are not
the people that we had before they're
totally different it's been an amazingly
which great news week really fantastic
it's great to see Lois and Peter moving
the business forward with new customers
and new ideas um we've had the till move
from downstairs when we closed when when
you were here when we closed down we had
someone do all rewiring and put this in
here but crucially how's the new menu
doing I don't know if the boys told you
but on Friday we sold out of seafood 40
covers on Tuesday and 50 covers on
Wednesday so um you know selling out of
seafood you know we never used to do
that can the business
survive if it continues is going on like
this now yes since I was last here
turnover has nearly doubled to 14 half
Grand a week so they must be getting
something right good time to find out
for myself I have a look at the um Bar
menu but I'm not going in there to eat
oh no you can eat in here that's fine
wow that's great thank
you good big breakthrough Christ I'm in
the same place I was a month ago and
Lois is outside um as a host checking
customers coming through um arranging
the table plan and um almost slightly
looking concerned which I like to see a
worded that means she's moving around I
think it's getting much better it's much
calmer the whole system is working the
first time he came to ET he
was was chewing on raw sushi rice I want
to see if the big bad Jordi has regained
his passion for
food so I've challenged him to cook me
something special special with my seab
bass all
right hope it's more successful than the
last
[Music]
day
go on then what no just the face let me
ask you a question first yeah um what
did you think of the Seabass I thought
it was following along the themes uh
straightforward not complicating the
flavors I think if I was to have that
dish on the menu uh I think it would
probably fly out the door I thought the
dish was um absolutely fantastic yeah I
already enjoyed it excellent and that's
the best dish I've eaten at the sangate
hotel since I've been
here next time I see you yeah you're
going have a baby girl or a baby boy you
know you know what it is go on youa
that that I cont yes
I that was a night was it I think it
might have be like that Cass was
memorable what more could you ask right
and don't tell him I didn't really catch
it I bought it from the [__]
fishmonger I really think this can work
you know that they've got all the
ingredients and I think they can really
put this place back on the map and be a
great Seaside Restaurant it needs a lot
of hard work and understanding that your
customers are [__] important nothing
more than
that this is Blackpool it's
what and this is blackpool's R of the
year uh you never call out the orders
yeah but I mean I'm I'm struggling in me
own mind at the minute no no really this
is blackpool's rest of the year table
two two moves one bread and butter
pudding have I got it I'm [__] I'm
destroyed that's how I feel I feel like
I never want to [__] cook again and
this is how not to run a restaurant we
can't cook a [__] muscle you [__]
yeah clonker
[__]
Blackpool is Britain's biggest and Brest
Resort home to the nation's favorite
sealess comedians and an unprecedented
choice of chip shops love it or loathe
it this place doesn't do anything by
halves used to come to Blackpool all the
time with Mom and Dad in fact this time
of year to come and have a look at the
lights and um mom used to go and play
Bingo would you
[Music]
believe same TRS same lights same noise
and same freezing weather [__] it's cold
catering for the massive 12 million
tourists that come here every year there
are more than 650 places to eat and I'm
looking for the one that's been crowned
Blackpool tourist boards R of the year
is that it that can't be
it actually looks like a sex shop having
co-managed a restaurant in the local
casino 46- yearold Dave Jackson and
30-year-old partner Dawn Brindley pulled
their life savings to offer Blackpool a
unique Oasis of homecooked Cuisine it's
got a cracking atmosphere when there's
people in it it's lovely and ab I I love
it and to see it empty we did it last
night we stood here for 3 hours and I
just could have gone home in tears 18
months later they're barely breaking
even with turnover at a poultry £500 a
week we won an award we've got pretty
good
reviews but we still can't get people up
the stairs it's very depressing putting
food fresh food in the bed in after 2 or
3 days it's only the ground floor greasy
spoon that's stopping them from going
under morning good morning clubway this
is it upstairs first floor Resturant of
the Year yes sir in clubway upstairs
restaurant dawn looks after the front of
house and comes up with the menu ideas
while Dave rustles them up in the third
floor kitchen Hi D hi Gordon so this is
it this is it yeah this is my little bit
excellent what's that you doing there
butter peaches saatana bread and butter
pudding popular very popular uhh
occasionally uh I forget about
them oh [__] yeah and the most popular
dis on the menu what are they main
coures chicken's popular Lamb's quite
popular this sounds intriguing flake
salmon with
strawberries yeah that was popular top
with lemon and lime and honey dressing
yeah soup of the moment what does that
mean soup of the moment it's whatever
whichever one we do rather than put on
an actual soup so like I mean we do
tomato and contro at the moment we've
got tomato and contro Jesus where did
that one come from so again I think
don't I came up with a tomato and she
added dantro so yeah it works well does
it yeah it flies out in order for me to
get up to speed I'd like to eat off it
okay fine no problem I'll see you in
5 that I wasn't expecting cuz nothing's
on as a starter I've ordered one of D's
favorite dishes thank you a salad of
salmon and strawberries with a lime and
honey dressing no one's ever been in my
kitchen and now I'm cooking for Gordon
Ramsey and my fingers won't work my
brain won't work what can I do a three
course meal at clubway cost between 20
and £25 there we go and pray for that
price in Blackpool Dave's food can't
afford to be anything less than perfect
thank you very
[Music]
much what was going through somebody's
mind putting salmon with
strawberries that can go off the end of
the
pier
next Jo I used think it was bad cooking
for the Mother-in-law day's clearly out
of
practice but then this place is like the
Mary
Celeste okay just explain what it is
please okay we've got medallions of pork
on a bed of spring on your mushed potato
the sauce is Bri and nectarine and we
have P crisp an compliment oh
paprika
hot thank
you very tough the
pork it's been
battered and beaten heavily you'd
struggle to give that to a dog bits of
parsnip rubber they're supposed to be
crisp by the
way a Bria nectarine sauce
is [__]
disgusting we'll skip the pudding time
for a de
breath I just hope Dave and daor have
got stronger stomachs than I
[Music]
have
okay we need to talk okay I didn't
expect it to be that bad cuz everything
was rough yeah trust me the combination
of a hot Bree nectar rings and whiskey
that's probably the worst Source I've
ever tasted in my entire life overcooked
in sepid pork and badly put
together right okay yeah so work to do a
lot of work to do okay by the way the
mash wasn't
bad got one F
crying Le have been told him [__] but
the best that's [__] brutal that was
Mash wasn't bad though that's something
how this place ever won anything other
than a [__] booby prize I'll never
know and if there was a rule book this
place would be the classic example on
how not to run a [__]
restaurant starting with rule number one
don't assume winning an award means
people will know who you are and where
you are um do you know where clubway 41
is it's black black pool's rest of the
year n no it's around here just off the
prominade no I'm going to hello mate is
blackpool's sort of Resturant of the
year The Hot Spot since when yeah this
year in fact ladies have you heard of
clubway 41 at
restaurant nobody seems to have even
heard of the place it's black Paul's
rest of the year never heard of it oh
God but remarkably it seems the award
really is genuine I've just found the um
forms for the nomination for the black p
tourism awards some of the best fresh
food we've ever eaten varied menu C for
most taste yeah I'll say taste from a
[__] cow's backside to a pig's
[__] snort I would honestly say this
is has been the best meal I've ever had
in my life honestly in Brackets a truly
Unforgettable experience well [__] me
I've had an unforgettable experience I
catching decco someone's pulling my
[__]
[Music]
plonker yesterday I spent my first day
at clubway
41 black Ball's failing R of the year
and quite frankly I don't know where to
start
quro come on P next
R Dave and dor have already lost two
houses in an effort to stay afloat and
if they're not careful they'll lose
their last remaining Lifeline the
downstairs greasy spoon that's just
about keeping their bank manager at
Bay try to Freez mik it's one of those
days where I really just want to be
somewhere else today it's time to bring
Dave Dawn and their food back to the
real well how you feeling this
morning totally
destroyed um listen you've got to bounce
back yeah and I I ate that food last
night and I was honest I'm [__] I'm
destroyed yeah that's how I feel I feel
like I never want to [__] cook again
you're a tough cookie and you're
resilient and you've been through the
meal before and you know what's good and
know what's bad I'm here to
help and I'm not going till I get it
right I'll take I'll take the [__]
[__] yeah
but bounce back I will I
will if he thinks that's pressure well
wakey wakey mate get a grip look for
your bollocks and once you found them
then start using them they seem far cool
so
far in order for me to really see what
you're like and understand your
capabilities I've got 20 people coming
for lunch
today okay now yep okay um they got to
be in and out in an hour and a half
they're coming at
2:00 it's been a long time since Dave
had 20 customers to cook for and he's
clearly
petrified so I'm hoping to enlist the
help of a man who's been coping ably
with pressure since I arrived order
table five Nigel the short order cook in
the ca
downstairs um so when you get a rush on
how many orders come on at
once uh well the cafe could be empty at
one stage then all of a sudden there it
can be full all 12 tables you're on your
own and how many customers have you done
in one day at Max what's the what's the
most you're going about 250 300 easy and
that's on a good Saturday bu yes very
much so yeah very much so yeah the buz
the adrenaline is amazing two minutes
for the breakfast bab Nigel may spend
most of his days cooking bacon butes but
I wouldn't mind betting he's a solid man
to have by your side okay going on table
to to breakfast way especially when
you're as jittery as Dave is I've got a
problem with with the Bri NEC TR sauce I
haven't got any nect trains right can
know well have you ever tasted it
without the nect TR no have you ever
tasted it with just a simple gravy yes
finished with fresh Rosemary so forget
the Bree sauce right okay yeah that's
fine as a 46y old Chef Dave's naivity is
beginning to shock me I'm going to start
off with a quick red wine sauce but it
turns out he's hardly set foot in a
kitchen since he trained in the
70s you don't sash the garlic down she
put it in like that all I did was just
crushed it nightly just with the heir of
the knif exactly that how not to run a
restaurant rule number two never appoint
yourself head chef if you can't cook
when we bought this place to save on
money you know I took the roll of up
here and then Dawn we know was perfectly
capable of running the
restaurant and where does dwn get these
ideas from vivid
imagination she's I mean a lot of the
stuff she does come up with last year I
mean it worked and it worked well but we
got no customers yeah I know well so how
did it work did it work for you did it
work for her or cuz it didn't work for
the restaurant no yeah all right I can't
win that argument cuz I got an empty
restaurant so taste that that's where
the that's where the that's where the
flavor is don't get that out of
tender our 17 customers are local
dancers who've hot footed it here in
between show
they need to be in and out within an
hour and a
half the food's prepped and the
restaurant's only half full and with
Nigel by his side Dave should be able to
go thank you sir need to see the kitchen
Under Pressure mhm so um I know he's
your boyfriend yeah y but give him some
work to do bring him
ony you ready sure no I put me 3 Ines of
water in the bottom of that mate
dealing with several orders at a time is
standard practice in the kitchen so
first order on but within seconds of
receiving the first Bunch Dave's
flapping about like a headless
chicken yeah okay Don right you just put
me four checks in yeah who's in
first okay yeah they're both came in
together we got both the checks at the
same time big deal [__] and whilst he's
been panicking about the orders Dave's
burnt the custard it's Kem l
fck so that's on that's on the chicken
did you call out the orders Dave so
sorry you ever call out the orders yeah
but I mean I'm I'm struggling in my own
mind at the minute so right how not to
run a restaurant rule number three if
you lose all powers of communication
Under
Pressure you shouldn't even be in the
kitchen give do anything Dave you've
clammed up you've talked to him tell him
what you want him to do I'm not sure
sorry I'm not sure myself so it's your
[__] restaurant I know it's my
restaurant right get me a piece of
pork ni Dave you looking the [__]
already I am yeah you
are the customers have been here 27
minutes and they still haven't had a
sniff of
grub okay I'm going to be nearly ready
to go in a minute on the first table
Yeah e thank you the food has finally
started to leave the kitchen
[Music]
but whether it's edible or not is
another
matter it's depressing they're cooking
for a dining room that's only half full
but for Clow to survive it needs to be
completely Chalker at
weekends very difficult to keep people
placated when you're not Bing anyone we
not give him
all I'll
pay [__] me it's been a long time it's
hard I'm getting no feedback from dawn
so I'm I'm like I'm running blind
Running Blind at a minute and not what
feedback do you need right now well
really is is everybody okay is anyone
you know starting to sort of like winge
cuz they're waiting or it's relax relax
you're all over the shop like a [__]
rangan you cool down and just relax and
get yourself composed I think you do a
10 times better job yeah yeah I know
yeah you're right yeah yeah without
getting paranoid our guests have to
leave in 15 minutes and they haven't
even started on desserts yet
you've got to
yeah table two two moves one bread but
pudding have I got it yeah you go right
table seven four moves have I got
it R of the Year Blackpool yeah [__]
hole of the year um yeah making hard
work and nothing really all over the
place completely disorientated his own
kitchen very bad at delegation and
totally in a mess I can't think of two
things at once 17 guests that's all it
took him 1 hour and 5 minutes to cook
for 10 people and the last seven guests
taking 45 minutes shocking so you have
three first one banana is what you're
going what I was asking you okay that's
fine right tell me that in the first
place I [__] answer go around [__]
hous together oh dear oh
dear it spare room
again it's the end of the season for
Blackpool tomorrow night the
illuminations will be switched off and
the tourists will go home from what I've
seen so far it will be a miracle if
clubway 41 survives the
winter right
Dave stop cooking like a r of
t stop monking
around and bananas are off the
menu thank you very much thank
you by day three it's clear in my mind
that there's only one way forward
simplify the food and simplify the
preparation but first I want to give
Dave and Nigel senses a wakeup call get
those on yeah up you got to really rely
on your taste buds now how not to run a
restaurant rule number four if your
chefs can't distinguish between Heavenly
and hellish food combinations then your
customers won't be coming back for more
Dave what can you taste there
uh B Basel what about something meaty
it's like very rare beef yeah what my
fingers please remember this one Dave
signature dish even my six-year-old
daughter would know this is a culinary
Calamity Dave talk to me about that one
what what flavors can you identify tread
away
cheese yeah pineapple yeah pineapple
cheese I think what it is is it like a
shellfish like a scolar when you you
brush your teeth in the morning do you
use toothpaste or
cigarettes cuz you got a mouth like a
cow's
backside there right
there
good
Olive tomato do those flavors work
together yeah they do yeah they
definitely work together yeah one of my
favorites yeah ready for the last one
the evil salmon of strawberry starter
open why that Dave swears is so popular
on his menu first of all nice would you
be happy to pay money for
that no not this no on that one I
wouldn't not to my taste no it doesn't
work for me doesn't work for me nect and
pork okay take the [__] blindfolds
off that last stick had your salmon and
strawberries and [__] Water Crest on
there yes yeah if it doesn't work in
your [__] pallette what chance has it
got working in a restaurant yeah point
taken very much so very very
constructive that dear oh dear oh dear
now I need to be sure the creative
Mastermind behind clubway disastrous
current menu Isn't about to sabotage our
painfully slow progress my question is
what gives you the right to think of
these ideas and then in your own mind
think that it's right for the customers
when you haven't seen it before just
experiment really just try and put
different flavors together we we've
tried because we've tried so many menus
and to try and fill the restaurant we
have done plain and then we've gone the
Avenue well maybe um we are too plain
and people can make this at home and
unfortunately it's not working no I mean
until you've actually put it as plainly
as you have done yesterday and today and
actually gone through there's too many
flavors going on because the business is
disintegrated and there's no customers
you're digging deep but you're Lively
you're a live wire and that's a healthy
sign in a business you know it needs
that energy but I think what you've got
to really understand what your telling
Dave to do he's not capable of doing
right okay the restaurant is empty and
the next stage is to close it we're not
going to close it we're going to look at
clever simple combinations put them back
on the menu and get back to something
that sounds in touch with Blackpool
okay clubway food isn't just
unappetizing it's packed with costly out
of season ingredients that reflect in
its overpriced menu you I could use
anything on it didn't he I've decided to
challenge DA's perception of Simplicity
by giving him a tray full of ingredients
to make a broccoli soup he can use as
many or as few as he seeds fit but it's
got to be
good okay is it finished yeah it little
taste should taste broccoli I can taste
little bits of broccoli tastes a bits
but you can't taste the flavor can't
taste flavor exactly water onto the boil
my recipe consists of broccoli yeah and
broccoli and broccoli and broccoli and
broccoli boiling rapidly I can't believe
it's that simple Sor because once we've
cooked the broccoli in that water we're
then going to strain it yeah and add the
water back to the
broccoli Dave's simple broccoli soup
contains 16 ingredients including pricey
cream and butter mine is just three
broccoli salt and water it cost Pence
and it took a lot less time to make have
a
taste I love the color what's the first
thing that comes into your mind God that
is so tasty of
broccoli so you taste and it gives me
that sense of Christ that's moish I want
more because it tastes of
broccoli understand and the next one
little taste of that one Dave likes it
but what about these mes which one would
you pay
for I don't like either you don't like
either no [__] hell that's too plain
in that's to from now on you're staying
out the kitchen nothing to do with your
food nothing to do with any Tangerine
nectarine [__] mango I'm never going
to look at one ever again fantastic Dave
you're now in control of your kitchen
thank you okay [__] off thank
you how not to run a restaurant rule
number five don't give your
establishment a name that makes it sound
like a strip
joint clubway 41 first floor restaurant
license Cafe Resturant [__] hell got
to think of name something positive
something that Rings what's your surname
mine Brindley brindley's brindley's
beastro Cafe H what's your surn name
Jackson Jackson sounds good and
it's Jackson you enough to marry me babe
aren't you so I'm a Jackson too even
more pressure now everything costs me
money are you proposing isn't it your
job to propose it's the love of my life
so we'll take a day off easy take a day
off and I'll marry you so long as it's
on the cards then yeah yeah yeah I'm
ja yeah we'll that we got you sure now
very yeah and are you settled on that
100 100
100% the Bria nectarine fog that's been
surrounding Dave appears finally to be
lifting are you in touch with blackp
what's all the chefs using at the moment
what's the what's the latest big thing
what's caught locally what's from the
fish market what's down the veg Market
no then i' have to put hand on heart and
say no no cuz I'd rely on with suppliers
yeah we lost Direction it's gone badly
wrong and youve got to keep your ear
close to the ground so what do you want
from Blackpool I want people to come and
have good
honest food uhhuh that's it in that
shop that's what I want and how far are
you away from that now
miles probably further than we are from
the restaurant
now it takes a brave man to acknowledge
his business is on the brink of collapse
but I've not given up hope on Dave
yet we've hit rock bottom yeah we've hit
rock bottom now we're going up and if
you can't stand the heat [__] off out
the kitchen [__] off out the kitchen
hold on tight I am [__] holding
on
[__] [__]
hell really pleased to see the back of
that yes it's my fourth day in Blackpool
and its Resturant of the Year clubway 41
is no longer yeah look look look all
coming down Fant fantastic from today
this place will be known simply as
Jackson's Darren can you get that
[__] banner down as well please yeah
it would give that back to the tourist
board but even with a facelift we're
still breaking a cardinal rule in how
not to run a restaurant [__]
name rule number six first floor
establishments are notoriously difficult
to fill so to give Dave and Dorn's new
Venture of fighting chance I've come up
with a radical idea I think you're
missing a real serious trick here this
Cafe functions brilliantly during the
day and I think we should
look at moving the restaurant and
operating the restaurant from here in
the evening but I stood outside last
night and I looked I thought God that
Frontage restaurants would die for that
kind of Frontage out there it's not new
is it really no it's not you the
kitchen's on show there's an atmosphere
going on there's a bit of banter you got
all the bus stops all the locals going
home yeah when someone walks past that
and they see this play for what are they
going to do want to eat them they want
to come in and eat it is a nice room to
work and plus no buzzes no phone I can
see David it's oneon-one they can see
him and it's more of a a partnership for
the two of us then the customers are
coming in and seeing us both in our
environment not Dave stuck in the
kitchen and popping down when he can so
can't pour drug of milk over his head
down here but we have got a seller
aren't we
in tomorrow night we've invited 50
influential people to launch the new
name1 and to match its fresh clean
exterior we've come up with a fresh
clean simple menu have you made a castle
before no no you never made a castle
before no never [__] me 47 years AG 30
years ago probably at cing College it's
time to nail rule number seven don't
attempt to cook elaborate food before
you've mastered the very Basics we'll
start off with just roasting off the
vegetables right and then we'll Brown
the meat put it all into a pot and let
it cook nice and slow about an hour and
a half I've got just 36 hours to teach
Jackson's inept head chef how to cook
Nigel you're doing the potatoes yes once
they finished we're going to make a fish
St right yeah that's going to be our
base for fish
[Music]
soup lamb beauy colored off see look how
dark it is that there is all about
Flavor there that whole thing there is
just pure flavor using inexpensive
produce fresh from the local markets 90%
of this new food can be prepared in
advance dishes like lamb casserole pork
tarine and fish soup are designed to
take the heat off during service in
that's it nicely mixed good the aim is
to get Dave and Nigel sending out
delicious tasty food to a dining room
full of customers without Dave having a
nervous breakdown in the process you're
free you're free to control it and do it
properly without having to do 20 things
at once yeah understand next up we're
prepping some locally caught fish for a
deliciously simple soup right Gordon
just give me a hand here will you please
yeah do the knife yeah then watch it all
the way down to the tail yeah off right
eyes out yep and just cut it up into
quarters any specific way or just well
it's only for a fish talk Dave so
whatever way you feel fit okay this is
like pulling teeth anyone that hasn't
actually killed a castle before yeah or
feted fish shouldn't be roing a [__]
restaurant so let's get cracking on with
the fish soup cook off your muscles and
we'll save the juice yeah have you
cooked muscles before
no you're pulling my plonka now aren't
you you've never cooked a muscle all
right we can shout or you can [__]
help I don't mind what do you mean I can
help what have we been doing for the
last yeah okay fine you're right I'm
sorry what I've been doing for the last
2 hours fine so what we want in here I'm
just amazed you've never cooked a muscle
I haven't don't take the piss out of me
for it though oh who's taking the piss
you are I don't think you can actually
cook if you have [__] talk you can't
cook a [__] muscle you have [__]
talk go on yeah finish it then finish
what what you about to say are what am I
about to say cook a muscle no I haven't
cooked one right okay so shall I show
you how to cook a muscle oh at last
thank you yes please right are you going
to turnone your voice down or you going
to shout like some dick I'll shout like
some dick and then I'll calm down right
now shout why [__] off to the book shop
read how to cook a muscle and come back
and see me and I'll run your [__]
Resturant thank you plonker
[__] [__] him out what's all that about
Jesus Christ well at least we broke the
ice now anyway we know where we stand
yeah 5 minutes after he put his toys
back in his pram Dave returned ready and
willing to learn how to cook muscles
we're doing is steaming them now not
quite we've done more in the last
[__] hour than we have in 3 days yeah
yes I know more about you and you know
more about [__] me yes true Chef
thank you Gordon Gordon [__] the chef
yeah rule number eight don't assume you
can run a restaurant just because you've
worked in one sometimes you know when I
listen to you talk about food and the
way you are in a kitchen I'm concerned
you fall in love with becoming a great
chef but forgot to go through the
Journey to get there what do you mean by
a great chef I mean to reach good no no
[__] all to do with me you're not
working for someone else now you're
working for for yourself and you know
this is on its ass the business can't
get any worse I just don't want you to
get in a situation where you think that
you're going to be blackpool's best chef
cuz for as long as you got a hole on
your ass that's never going to happen
all
right dve and dwn would be better off
with a new chef but they simply can't
afford one right now there he is mooki
the clown has agreed to try and works
and miracles with what we've
got now that man's got amazing
coordination skills that's good that's
good that's it slow like that's
brilliant that's brilliant leading a
successful kitchen takes tremendous
concentration so all we doing with is
creating that momentum honey you've got
to constantly be thinking ahead to keep
on top of the
game just like being in a kitchen yeah
yeah creating that momentum with great
coordination skills of table three table
four together putting two tables
together yeah sending three tables
together there we go now we have to take
them
off hit may be a crash course in control
in his kitchen but at last something
seems to be sinking
in Come On Dave you can do this
see
[Music]
one thank you very much take it
B with the launch of Jackson's
Restaurant just 12 hours away his new
downstairs venue is been treated to a
facelift
[Music]
it's goodbye to the old clinical Cafe
and hello to a warm and inviting
restaurant what a difference huh
brilliant it it looks absolutely amazing
really does looks absolutely smashing
very nice there's loads to do food for
the new simplified menu needs to be
prepared practiced we waste nothing and
perfected same amount for the bottom
same amount for the top 2 and 1 half
minutes each side I never thought of
having a r never the million years Ma
and just to make sure we're instigating
idiot proof measures down takes the air
out okay one nice portion so water's
boiling rapidly it goes in you cut the
top off and it's away it couldn't be
easier but AR's first night is
everything and the team can't afford to
put a foot
wrong David it's your Resturant yeah big
Knight is there anything you think that
you can't do no nothing yeah anything
you want to change no happy with it lamb
Castle bring it back to the ball middle
of the plate meet in the middle
dumplings on the side pushing pushing in
here push push push push question
question question run it through your
mind then it becomes fluent fluid happy
[__] customers full dying room and
everything moves okay okay the newly
incarnated Jackson has got to be a slick
operation Jackson that looks nice two
cses £4 3 CES £8 Darren that doesn't
sound expensive does it two cses £4
three cses £8 cheap that looks
nice hey welcome to Jackson's nice new
Immaculate hats proper hats just do me a
favor you look the part cook the part
good luck everyone thank you very much
stay cool stay calm yes and communicate
oh our first customers hey guys I'm our
first customers yes you are good evening
it's nice to meet you welcome to Jackson
ladies from the tourist board don't
mention the
[Laughter]
banner you
I feel like I'm just about to light the
fuse and let it
explode it's a huge gamble putting Dave
and his nerves on show but maybe an
audience is exactly what he needs to
[Music]
focus C's happy nice nice Buzzy
restaurant we'll give it that way
is here we go one check on please okay
one macro salad one soup one lamb one
steak Dave's off to a good
start how
long David that's good talking yes he's
got a confidence about him I haven't
seen before and he appears to be in
control thank you service please table
two two TP one
MW okay got table two's Ma and P and
there's your bread okay I'm want to go
with table 10 Mains then table seven
star
first main course now first main course
now to 10 let's go service please way to
10 the plates are spinning but will Dave
be able to keep them up come on
guys okay nicely seasoned Nigel's been
as clear and concise with his steaks as
he is with his bacon and eggs one steak
medium one steak medium well medium well
darling medium table two okay table two
gone Dave thank
you okay service please table one one
Pate one
tart thank you check please even in its
Heyday this place has never been so busy
thank you service please table five sup
and there's nothing more alluring to
potential customers than an attractive
buzzing
restaurant there's nothing difficult
here soup to reheat everything's cooked
even the potatoes are cooked all they
have to do is dress the salad Grill the
Macon put it onto a
plate got anything else was it that was
T what have you just sent n five take
the fish that yours yeah I've got yeah
time to get your lemon but 50 minutes in
and the kitchen's having trouble keeping
Pace okay start okay right now what I'm
doing now dve right we go we go with
these starters sorry those plates are
beginning to wobble David don't burn any
of that Mac or we need everything that's
on order now you know sorry don't burn
that Mackle I won't be here next week so
Dave and Nigel have got to prove to each
other that they can do this on their own
hey STS coming now please okay I'm doing
now table nine starters okay and then
we'll all the rest will just come out
together yeah can we serve some more
champagne for those people that haven't
got starters or some wine or something
yeah keep just keep them
[Music]
happy I got off to Great star now it's
going really PR because there actually
Six Tables waiting for the starters I
need seven and six next but I need the
starters on
eight Mikey Mikey on P mate
please and you got a state well done
I've only got one state you here yeah
I've only got one state left I did say
that Dave's plates are no longer
wobbling they're crashing down around
him I haven't got the steak I can do the
an hour after they ordered customers
have been told their choice of main
course is no longer available and we
need these customers back I've the
starters yet so already we've gone back
to the table said we got no Stak so how
long for those starters Dave 11 okay
there's your need 11 and 12 okay fine
watch those Stakes that's all we've got
left you know that two medium well
please okay
okay despite all the delays Dawn's
waiting team have managed to keep the
customers happy they gave us an extra
glass of champagne that was lovely
that's made our
night little bit chipsy now but we're
all right I'm NY please the food has
looked hell of a lot
better the
started was beautiful I really enjoyed
that we've had a wonderful evening and
and the food well uh if it's all around
my mouth I'm
sorry even more miraculously Dave has
got through it service please without
having a nervous breakdown done
[Music]
done it's not perfect by a long chalk
but they've come a hell of a long long
way in a
week the following morning Dave and dwn
have had a booking for 10 based on a
recommendation from last night you can't
get better feedback than
that morning morning Gordon how are you
well morning D you well thank you
there's a present and I want it for you
you want it for
me is it a coordination challenge it's a
r it yeah keep it as a good luck mask ni
how are you feeling yeah very well
positive about last night actually just
sort of you know give us another two
three services there and uh we have it
Top Notch it's not until you work
something that you find it pitfalls so
and now we worked it and we saw the
pitfalls so now we know which areas to
look in Dawn Sparkle and energy are
perfect for front of house I just need
to be sure she'll steer well clear of
that menu last night I stood outside and
just looked and saw the resturant full
you busy and buzzing it was great and
feeding off the customers and bouncing
off it's the base now the start for
something that we think is going to
really take off yeah my concerns with
David is I don't want him getting Beyond
his station again I don't want you
filling his head with brie no believe me
it's never going to happen again I've
listened to it no menus this is my bit
that's his bit no menus last night
worked and you so know it [__] works
like that nothing more I want you to
keep hold of that it was nice it buzzing
again it's simple say it's it's all
about organization yeah but don't get
too ambitious and certainly don't turn
it into something pretentious because
that is going to close this place I know
money's time and finances are difficult
in time I want you to look for a new
Chef crucial yeah I'll agree with that
one more
thing keep the [__] nectarines in the
fruit salad yeah keep the nectaries in
the fruit salad yes not with [__]
battered out pork
there you go thank you look after that
lady I will do bye guys thanks thank you
drive carefully
please oh thank
you damn I forgot to mention rule nine
you're only as good as your last
service 8 months ago I came to Blackpool
on a mission to breathe some life back
into its failing rest of the Year table
two two moves one bread and but puding
have I got it but a quick resuscitation
for Club weight 41 was out of the
question that's probably the worst
Source I've ever tasted in my entire
life they were breaking every rule in
the book I don't think you can actually
cook if You' have [__] if you can't
cook a [__] musle
you the [__]
name but after a week we've moved Heaven
and Earth to make the new Jacksons a
going concern t one one Pate one t and
by the skin of our teeth we just about
pulled it off they gave us an extra
glass of champagne that was lovely
that's made our
night I left Dawn and Dave at the end of
blackpool's season with a Chance of
surviving a long Bleak
winter Summer's here and they're still
open how are you yeah very well thank
you yourself well on the surface the
place is looking great yeah just give me
a talk there oh please but it's soon
clear that things are far from Rosie and
where's uh n well nig's gone because n's
gone because I think it's probably best
off left like that you're missing a chef
God things must be bad I was hoping Dave
was going to recruit reinforcements in
the kitchen not get rid of them so
getting through the winter was the most
important thing which you managed to do
Ian we knew winter would be hard but we
didn't I didn't think it would be that
hard all the way through January
February we carried on nothing and then
we ended up with this bus station right
outside we can't have the door door open
in summer because the the fumes the
diesel fumes are disgusting this is a
terrible twist of fate they've just
about survived the winter and now a bus
exchange has landed on their doorstep
apart from physically drag these people
into the building I really don't know
what more we can do I mean we've worked
our asses off all year with debts at an
all-time high Dave and Dawn shut down
the evening restaurant just 2 months
after Jackson's relaunch it just seems a
a missed opportunity if you been that
idea so early when you you worked at it
for six seven weeks if I hadn't have
done it and and cut my C we wouldn't be
here now literally in a desperate effort
to save money in the cafe they've shot
themselves in the foot by outing
homecooked food they're back to box
standard Frozen Blackpool fair so just
Cafe food you're this breakfast yeah so
what about the specials the specials
they've been up there I mean we just
have the board up there now
if summer trade doesn't pick up soon
Dave and Dawn will lose everything you
thought about you have to speculate to
accumulate yeah of course they piss you
off but turn it around to your advantage
so I've come up with a unique marketing
strategy using the God awul busies to
bring fresh food and customers back to
Jackson's Cafe the idea is to track them
into the restaurant in the evening and
the kids eat for for free for free yeah
as an incentive through the summer 2005
and you know look delicious homecooked
evening specials after 600 p.m. very
good idea are you happy I'm happy with
that yeah thanks for that so for our
summertime special it's fresh fish and
chips from Mom and Dad and free homemade
chicken nuggets and mini burgers for the
kids so they're not coming to us [__] it
we're going to go to them we're doing
some homemade specials this evening um
if you order a special little girl a
leave for free everything's homemade so
we'll see you in about what half an hour
that's probably you
Corner Jackson's on Market you there yes
thank you on the adult special we've got
Fleetwood fresh cfish beer batter you
like burgers don't you big boy yeah give
you're too
slow at last a smile Dawn's a natural
saleswoman so why isn't she out here
every evening everything's homemade on
the premises fresh today fantastic
produce and we start at 6:00 this
evening what's your favorite food what
do you like cry
C's off the menu about 6:00 all right
thank you the past 8 months have clearly
been very hard but to survive you can't
let it get you
down you know the place is better than
the cafe I think that's my yeah that's
my my my my grip there must be 500 cafes
that serve full English breakfast in
Blackpool and if he's got any chance of
surviving you know you got to be better
than that [__] on the ass like that
and the business is so [__] weak
we've got no choice have we huh
come on don't be upset no I'm more right
going be silly come here come on don't
be silly
huh sorry don't be
Sil C be
strong should get back and cook some G
yeah what you fancy a swim no sniff well
you you're already
wet huh standing in a [__] swimming
pool let's go back
rest tonight's a chance to lift the bar
and convince the punters that Jackson
home-cooked fresh food is A Cut Above
the Rest are you set up for uh for
dinner I'm just about yeah I've just got
these but Dave and daor have got to
stick to their guns I was a little bit
myth this morning when I heard that it
only went for 6 weeks that's not long
enough to try it and I think what you're
doing is listening to the first or
second customer and then that's setting
your thoughts for the next three or four
months I I really had to look at the
cost big style yeah you know at the end
of the January Now The Season's here we
have the chance to evolve it in these
over the next like 12 to 14 weeks we got
to make noise Dave this is a you know a
cafe it's a smart place but you got to
get that message across and you got to
continue putting that message Out
[Music]
There Our PR exercise has paid off the
customers are flocking in 2 minutes for
your gar that's fine thank you Dave's at
home cooking this kind of food and it's
flying out okay I need four gons out
please and the home cooking seems to be
hitting the
spot
[Music]
it's nice crispy bath very tasty and the
Cod that's delicious you can do it this
is
simple might actually ask him for the
[__] recipe child's Burger child's
burger no chips okay well I'm convinced
how about the kids where's it gone have
you eaten it all well done out of 10 how
many would you
Market would you give 100 that means it
was a really good burger the meal deals
been a real success and the fresh food
has proved its worth the food was 100
times better customers were happy
weren't they yeah kids were in there we
had to go off the street and drag them
in but you know that's what's going to
take to get this place back great honest
food that will fill a restaurant really
yeah yeah yeah it's not that difficult
yeah is it no no this is a rule book cuz
when I first came to Jackson's or
clubway at the time yeah it was
everything Ares shouldn't be read this
there's one special rule rule number 10
don't think your life saving into
opening a restaurant if you're in any
doubt of success if I asked you to turn
the toop Back 2 years would you have
vought clubway 41 knowing what I know
now yeah no but hindsight's always an
exact science but with what we've
learned we will carry and it will work
look what you've been through yeah don't
bin it read me another rule before I go
my lucky number number seven don't
attempt to cook elaborate food before
you've mastered the basics and that is
one thing we definitely learned from
your last visit yeah good Sound Advice
Sound Advice lovely bedtime reading
tonight bedtime reading Big Time hey
good good to see you and you yes yeah a
get a kiss Dave and dor have been
through the mill but if they can stay
focused for the rest of the season they
might just be here next
year did you actually get a shot you
don't get a shot
now this is where David needs to sit
inside so we can wake him up and get his
numb [__] head out of his Bri and
nectarines and get back to some good on
his
food the [__]
H this week I'm in Derby for my big
biggest challenge yet a God awful
Italian restaurant that's stuck in a
Time War it sounds like prices that were
in existence [__] 10 15 years ago a
truly miserable kitchen I've been saying
it for 3 days we haven't got a pot
washer nobody's done a [__] thing
about it with appalling food the chicken
raw and I don't want to catch salmonella
in [__] Derby unless I can help her
new owner danela has just spent half a
million quid on a sinking ship we might
as well close down now and I can save my
[Music]
money when the gond opened in 1968 its
Italian owners brought the lammer of
Venice to dowy
Derby and it instantly became the place
to be seen you couldn't get into this
place unless you book two or 3 weeks in
advance the place was packed had
wonderful atmosphere and it had a reput
ation then of being the best restaurant
in Derby Daniela celebrated her 21st
birthday at Londa she even got married
in the restaurant she loves it so much 6
months ago she bought the company but
just what had she
bought go [__]
hell my bay in Derby [__] hell the
size of it a 125 seater restaurant with
a 21 bedroom hotel attached a big
undertaking especially if the state of
the outside is anything go by [__] me
even the gond looks
[__] hello hello good evening Mr an
Gordon Gordon and Daniela Daniel how are
you fine all the pleasure to seeing you
thank you for coming to our not at all
God it's a uh it's uh it's like going
back in time it is it's a bit of a Time
Walk how old is it um nearly 40 years
old really even the floorboards are I
know crey crey as well fantastic anyone
under there uh no there's the wine s my
lovely old wine so yes Fant go through
it's Friday night 8:00 and you can hear
a few clinking plates in there but um
the place sounds empty how many book for
dinner four four yes a table of four and
that's all and that is our problem we
have this beautiful restaurant and it's
empty most of the time one question I've
got to ask why the hell did you buy it
if you've never ran a restaurant or a
hotel before well when my mother died
and I went through a divorce it was the
one thing one night that kept me going
and I thought that's what I'll do I'll
buy londra and all night long I just
dream to this place oh some customers
coming now
sorry okay good night good night did you
enjoy dinner yes thanks
excellent damn I think they left the
teeth on the table from its 70s
chandeliers to its plastic flowers the
restaurant is well and truly past
him no
excuses it's like stepping back in time
in it is and I wondered whether should
we really decorate it or wait till the
fashion turns and come back to it I mean
but it'll be too late if the business
goes down the pan
first everywhere you look um it's like a
flashback to the 70s even the food
sounds you know that dated smoke salmon
honeydew melon with Port warm Bree with
a tomato tart the menu is massive nearly
100 dishes and very few of them actually
Italian um I'd like to start with the um
spagh bise please
spetti the food's Italian yes say it's
fresh spaghetti it is thank
you I've ordered the simplest starter on
the menu but it seems to be taking a
very long
time get him on some [__] prop or
spaghetti now he's going to give the
[__] ancient [__] that was in there
Garth Garth GTH G you you do
it apologize don't worry problem in the
kitchen that's been water oh love nice
thank
you he apologized about the weit cuz he
said the Pastor was cooked to order
which if you only got four customers in
the evening [__] writ is going to be
cooked to
order big portions for
stter 6 is
huge I'm mounting a spag bowl and a
salon main course to come all for £650
no wonder they're losing
money right Gareth see if you can get a
tender lobster soup without seeing
you I've just seen something very dodgy
the silver serving vegetables and even
in 1999 Silver Service on vegetables
like that was 25 years too late the
salmon is also massive and like the
restaurant a bewildering trip through
time as the years have progress have
just added more onto it oh [__] it it's
1975 let's stick a muscle on
there ah [__] it it's 1980 let's stick
some MCH to on there do you know what
it's 1985 ratou is in stick some
Ratatouille on there and it's 1990
welcome back the roast
SP quantity not quality a classic 1970s
mistake and surprise surprise head chef
Steve stra started here in 1975 good
good good I've never seen such massive
portions in my entire life right doesn't
need the prawns doesn't need the um
muscles it's described on the menu as
that so I've got to follow through with
what's on the menu but I mean you've
been here for that length of time you
could change that and just do a simple
poach s dish without all that I could do
I could do you know there's two ways in
this industry you move with the times
mhm well the times moves you and
unfortunately you've been caught in a
Time Warp
[Music]
in my experience when a rant's been
stuck in a rut for so long rot start
setting in staff get really lazy they
start cutting corners and I really need
to discover exactly what's going on
here today there's a 70th birthday party
in the restaurant functions are the life
of Londa but there's not even enough of
those to stop it dying on its
ass at the moment for this year I've got
nine weddings booked but really we
should be aiming for about 30 weddings a
year and then that would be very
nice with 25 covers it's a chance for me
to see how the kitchen copes when they
have more than four people through the
door I've done
four
MH 10 minutes in the kitchen's already
in trouble they've run out of fresh tuna
Stakes you know what you're going to
have to do plan B but knows what they're
going to do it's called Plan B do you
know about Plan B Plan B Plan B Plan B
no no I don't what's Plan B when he's at
home oh tin that's what it means
right tin tuna banged out on limp
lettuce my grand would have been ashamed
to have served that doesn't feel like a
kitchen no energy no excitement
no passion really and sort of care and
love for food just get it in the bowl
and [__] off out excuse me sweetheart
now there's a problem with the mains oh
sorry it's no sauce on oh no sauce all
playing all playing where does it say
plan on
there I can do about that Steve straight
on the phone to Stella the business
manager yeah it doesn't say plane on the
menu does it we we never save a
[Applause]
plane Chef's wrong again never the
office not really sort out on Monday it
would have said Lobster sauces wanted
Lobster Stella cocked up the order for
the lobster Source but instead of
rolling his sleeves up and getting on
with it Steve picks a fight are you
going upstairs tell I just asked Daniel
to come wash some pot
all well we got a pot washer I've been
saying it for 3 days we haven't got a
pot washer nobody's done a [__] thing
about it in charge of the kitchen Steve
it's your department see Dan you wash
your hands over then while they're all
iing the waiters are still serving the
main
course it's a shambles Londa wants to be
a high class restaurant and yet they are
slopping out reheated catering
rubbish Belgium apple
pie what's Belgium about it did you buy
them in yeah yeah okay right yeah yeah
but from a chef to Chef Point of View
you know Dam well an apple pie we we we
eyes clo yeah exactly so you're telling
me now that you're happier to buy them
in rather than make them at this moment
no I'm I'm happier to make myself but I
don't have the staff or the skills or
the time to do it okay how long does it
take to make an apple
pie half an hour 40
minutes Mich in yeah yeah what this guy
needs is a rocket up his
ass this is a [__] ddle for you isn't
it yep it's not exactly ball break in
here is it it has been in the past and
it can St going back talk today it's
almost like we're paying for your memory
today is quiet right bring it back I'll
still handle it [__] hell
okay Daniela sunk half a million quid of
her divorce settlement into Londa but
last year alone it lost 75 grand if she
doesn't open her eyes to what's
happening in her kitchen she'll be left
with nothing but memories and debts
let's people PR be honest you fell in
love with the place and you grew up in
it and you had your 21st birthday party
had your wedding here and you have
bought a [__] time bomb I've never
seen a kitchen like that that
just has so little atmosphere no um
banter no communication no vibrant let's
get ready for a great lunch it was um
turkey going in cook the day before
reheated um I'm horrified that we had
that you're telling me a Discerning
customer cannot tell the difference but
I think we've really got to pick up on
and wake up on is the fact that your
Chef can lose self-esteem by serving
that [__] they've carved a very
comfortable Niche out for themselves and
they've made a really comfortable bed to
lie in and unfortunately you're paying
the price for
that I'm pretty pissed off you know that
I'm not happy because what I saw
yesterday across the board I thought was
a [__]
disgrace lagondola and Derby at first I
thought this restaurant's problem was
that it was stuck in a Time Warp but it
goes far deeper than that
it's 10:00 and headchef Steve and his
number two Gareth are only just rolling
up for
work you wouldn't get away with that in
my kitchen especially as last year the
ran lost 75 grand these guys just don't
seem to be interested in turning the
place
around how much has the restaurant taken
this week barely yeah 500
quid yeah the salaries alone in the
kitchen are £1,000 if the restaurant
didn't have these functions that are
drip feeding into this
establishment you wouldn't have a job I
personally want to put a [__] rocket
up everyone's ass in here today to
really make them understand what you
should be doing and not bickering and
festering on [__] memories from 20
years ago that means [__]
[Music]
all it's Sunday lunchtime and there are
three diners at the
Gonda when there isn't a functional on
well nothing much happens in this
kitchen right we are away we're away
please Chef's away as well he's been
away for 30 [__]
years M's away Chef
please not quite ready not quite ready
this kitchen is like a retirement home
so how many evenings do you work a week
three 3 to four depends on the business
really yeah just to play by it it
varies yeah what a bizar
setup good afternoon afteron welcome
backk you they've been coming for 36
years 36 years wow amazing so you are
the asset yes so um if the food was to
change you wouldn't come back no no what
you've got you got Min Sou Min which but
L are going to have to risk losing their
three regular diners because this is a
terrible environment for an aspiring
young
Chef number two Gareth is he only 19 but
he's already given up he was good wasn't
he there must be Soldier strong when the
business is so quiet
no motivation wise
no it's boring yeah very boring when
it's quiet you're just like clock
watching until it's 10:00 so you can go
cuz we can't go early in case someone
does come no so it's just you just clock
watching all the time yeah I've only
seen one person in this kitchen with any
real drive or ambition and that
17-year-old Apprentice Danny Holden
you're right Danny boy he good job yeah
my pleasure that's where it all started
you know that I've been in there lonely
place in amongst all those bubbles huh
but trust me if you get your [__] to go
in there it goes from bubbles on top of
the sink to Bubbles in glass it's
champagne would you like a glass
champagne I'm not old
enough [__] it we'll sneak in the fridge
okay then yeah yeah Young Chefs need
encouragement but discipline is high on
Steve's list of
priorities I don't stand any nonsense
you don't stand any nonsense no and if
these don't make it they go I've told
them all out I don't I'm not standing
for nothing this one might not last a
week are you
ready yesterday yesterday was very close
I don't hang around with one warning and
two warnings no out the [__] back
door so what you're saying you're worse
than me what what no what I'm saying is
I don't like [__] yeah out to go is that
right Gareth you're no good you
[Music]
walk Steve thinks he can talk the talk
but can he really walk the walk it's I
checked out his store
covered God [__]
hell [__]
evidence so I mean it looks like fish
food doesn't it huh and it smells
[__]
disgusting there you go half a container
a plastic Minon
suit right now
we've seen it all smash um what in the
[__] a chef does with that I don't know
the new owner Daniela wants Londa to be
an authentic Italian restaurant and yet
she's completely unaware what's
happening in her own kitchen um the Min
stry soup is quite
a hmark it is it's very good it's
excellent almost as good as my mother's
uhhuh yeah um great why' you buy it in
Steve I don't buy it in I make it
myself so the containers are bought in
minist soup and the invoice is here what
we do would mix that 50/50 uhhuh we'll
sort to give half and half really it
seems to be yeah I'm not clear what do
you mean two bowls one of plastic no
would make half up with perhaps packet
and then put fresh in to it as well
Steve's penny pinching by bulking up the
fresh soup with powdered but the prices
are so out of date on the menu they're
hemorrhaging money on a daily basis the
cost of the Lamb nothing more just the
lamb cutlets that whole dish okay should
be on the menu at
1650 right you're selling
it at
£10.90 mhm but the scary thing is Steve
that you don't know that every time we
sell that lamb yeah we're losing 5 quid
yeah yeah and if we had a table of four
in today yeah and they walked in that
door I swear to God it'd be a lot easier
to [__] stop them at the door and say
there's your 5 [__] off might close down
now and I can save my money you know I'm
Guided by people who've been here for
years and they're telling me they can
make money out of that menu but you were
here in place in position as the manager
when this was put together you can blame
me all life it's my money Steve not
yours I know it's your money let's let's
carry on let's put a structure in place
just a minute just let's put a structure
per room per meal my restaurant and I
all I needed to do was cover costs all
right and I did more than cover costs on
that Stella who does all this not I
think you're sh Stella does this don't
go off saying this that and the other
you could be out of a job in a month's
time no one is taking responsibility for
londa's problems everyone just blames
each other I look at you and I get
really nervous because I think you're
the kind of cook that's just going to
[__] off out here you know that I think
you're going to get upset one day after
listen to the way you spoke to the owner
if that was me I would have sacked you
and My worry is you're so determined to
[__] work in this industry you need
to get excited you need to start cooking
[Music]
properly I've got to get these guys out
of this god- awful kitchen and try and
lift their morale so I'm taking them to
see one of Darby's most successful
businesses now yeah Gareth you drive
yeah we're going to look at some
[Music]
history
right let's go look at something
beautiful something that's moved with
time
Rolls-Royce
1933 look at it beautiful now the next
one is something quite interesting
because this was made in 1979 look at it
a bit of history that Rolls-Royce didn't
sit still yeah and get moved by The
Times They decided to move ahead of the
times the Phantom what's it like in
there Danny it's nice and
comy business and Steve what I'm trying
to say yeah they've moved on they
haven't just stood there and sort of
expected Rolls-Royce to sell and
unfortunately big boy when I first saw
your food I felt like I was stepping in
a time capsule yeah I get your point
it's it's it's it's marvelous it's
marvelous absolutely I know a chef's got
one of these you know that and you're
thinking Gareth what should I do rob a
bank or work hard rob a bank fcking now
bollocks should we nip around and see
your mom Danny
the engine that PS any successful
restaurant is its kitchen and like
Rolls-Royce lond is going to have to
create its own modern Classics I'm
starting with that lunch
menu what's the secret behind any good
Italian
restaurant Pasta Pasta exactly when was
the last time you made fresh pasta never
have here we go you're making it I'm
just going to tell you how to make it so
make it well in the center that's it I'm
keeping it simple so the chefs have got
time to get up to
speed out goes the old two course lunch
Manu for £650 in comes a fresh pasta man
with a salad and a glass of wine for
£8.95 season again see the color is
starting to change now cuz the saon
working on there fresh pasta is the
Hallmark of an authentic Italian
restaurant its Simplicity also makes it
a money spinner far cheaper than those
expensive lamb specials see the color of
it all of it ricotta in and I want you
to taste it as you're doing it there you
go now okay watch yeah like a parcel
exactly look fold it
over nip all the air out little finger
over left to right right to left use
your thumb and
push tot who'd like a
go yeah of course you're going to have a
go here we go we've only been making
past of 10 minutes and already the young
chefs look like they're enjoying
themselves I finally injected some
passion into this kitchen
good that you've just done that was 10
minutes ago that was your first one yeah
hey no about that your first you've
never made pasta and now you've made
your first ever torini that's very good
I've asked Danny The Apprentice to come
up with a couple of salads for the new
menu different kinds of tomatoes you got
there right what I've done is I've put
like tomato and that in The Mixing Bowl
good and with the slots and you put like
this that sort of stuff over it and okay
have a little taste eat with me and this
one is a is rocket and Parmesan good man
cheese that's
lovely but the gonda's problems aren't
just in the kitchen to help me relaunch
the sinking ship I've called in the boss
of the company that does all my
restaurants PR Joe
Barnes what' you recommend well it
certainly makes the first impression up
the creaky stairs wow hi Dan hello
amazing Chandelier and you look at the
dance floor just how many heels I've
been dancing on this you can kind of see
El Deco doing a special on you know
Interiors Frozen in time yeah um do you
think there's a sellable asset here do
you think you could sell this restaurant
my first feelings when I come in and I
don't mean to be negative are start all
over again this place badly needs a
refurbishment um you could refurb it you
can call it a new name and start over
and really relaunch it however being M
fine what it does have is a tremendous
amount of authenticity and kind of
kitchy appeal yeah and I love the sort
of you know the DOR columns and the
dance floor and I suppose you've got to
work with what you've got Daniela and
her business manager Stella need Joe's
help because so far their marketing
efforts have hardly set Darby a light I
can't even find it on here supposed to
be underr restaurants under
Continental oh there we go Jesus Christ
so we go past all these um relaxing
massage and all these wh houses um and
you come down here and then L Gonda try
our new menus booking has now been taken
I mean you know you've missed it I think
what you've got to do is identify what
your real strengths are here and that's
the family run business that's the the
Great Space you've got with the dance
floor and make them into selling points
you've got to have a Punchy message with
which you can appeal to your potential
customers now the rest reputation has
disappeared reputation hasn't
disappeared the problem is that people
have forgotten about lag Gondola it
hasn't got a bad reputation definitely
not so a good
reputation see again you're living in
the P I feel you're not being honest
with yourself it has a [__] reputation
it hasn't I'm telling you it has so
you've been to Derby and you've had a
word with all of the customers all of
the customers there are no customers the
place is empty so you're telling me that
the people who put adverts in the paper
Thanking us for a superb wedding Etc
you're missing my point if you just
listen to what I'm trying to tell you it
may make sense in a minute the add-ons
from having a successful restaurant is
phenomenal we haven't got that
reputation any longer the business is on
its ass and the functions over the last
10 years have depleted accepted there is
no reputation at lag Gonda and if you're
going to stand there and tell me it's a
good place when a chef Buys in Minon
soup no
chance we need to spread the word around
Darby that Londa is changing so I've
told Stella to get on the phone and
Round Up members of the city business
Community for a special lunch a great
way to get the message out and a chance
to see if Steve can lead his
team my father used to come here for
business lunches about 25 years ago
right but in recent times I have to say
it's not a place that I would have come
to the idea of this lunch today is to
get them in and out in 40 5 minutes we
banished Silver Service to speed up the
waiters but can Steve run his kitchen
fast enough to keep up well busy quiet
makes no difference to me I only know
one way and that's the way I do it check
on yeah you ready to roll with us yeah
good man this is the exciting part of
the day yeah okay let's I want you clean
around the plates yep yeah good boy
let's go one for Tata one for shutter
one t t
nice the new pasta dishes I've devised
are hitting the
spot three sends their
compliments that's that's a first
quality yeah not bad very good prices
well but a little bit slow coming out
just a little bit slow people having a
business Lun once again the lack of
organization has dropped the kitchen in
it Jesus
Christ come on guys there's got to be a
system in here somewhere Steve if you're
uh if you're confused yeah let me know
and I'll help you out yeah it's gone all
quiet you see you're not leading like a
head chef you understand where all these
three guys including Dan is coming
together at the same time but they got
to take your direction you know
that yeah when you ask for it we'll do
we'll do it fresh yeah outside in the
restaurant there are lots of customers
waiting but all the orders have become
mixed up after that so you sent table
for you three T Telly one no one Bretta
they've sent them they've just come back
so they're on coffee they've already
sent them my course I'm and now the
whole table has got the wrong dishes
okay start again any anyway it's it's
it's gone it's gone Stone
Cold what about the starters on table a
they have it already they've had them
why is it not crossed off Steve no
wonder the kitchen's confused so that if
you send the starters why AR you
Crossing it
off did two starters yeah this
is that was just 35 covers I'm planning
to completely re launched the restaurant
in only a couple of days time with
double the number of customers I'm
starting to wonder if Steve is really up
to it what what has come out today's
lunch you know that is how everyone just
works on their own you know that I've
seen no [__] team spr here whatever
no understanding no coordination and
bringing these guys together has been a
[__] nightmare I
know [__] know I tell you I'm finding
it hard I'm finding it really [__]
hard because it's not about teaching an
old boy New Tricks it's about getting
the old boy to wake up and stop being a
lazy bastard a simple rotto Bretta
frittata tlell of chicken and they're
still in the
ship L Gondola is up the creek without a
paddle the kitchen's getting by with
Bing apple pies and the STA don't pull
together I don't know which way you have
it you both in less than 48 hours a new
owner Daniela is relaunching the
restaurant I woke up at 5:00 this
morning uh don't know have to often
swear but I was [__] scared the trouble
is daniela's head chef has been Treading
Water opening a tin of tuna or a packet
of powdered soup I want to redesign the
menu for the relaunch but what can Steve
actually cook season I've asked him to
prepare me a dish using fresh
ingredients only so what's in there
butter we got butter red onions red
onions a little bit of olive oil yeah
fennel fresh fennel just a little bit of
orange zest mhm
flour and where did this idea come from
when I was at come we used to do it um
when I worked down in Oxford down so 35
years ago quite a long time yeah yeah
Steve is cooking me a dish of rustic
Italian
trout that smells gorgeous and then you
can dress it up yeah um as a little bit
mythed when you're frying the um the
Trap the fact you hadn't take the scales
off right so already I've got to eat
this but the part of [__] in my mouth
why didn't you scale the fish Sor just
time was time yeah it looks like you
forgot I think that's pretty
dismal for a 51y old Chef to produce
that part of [__] I'm [__]
gobsmacked the scales are on there it's
all in the roof of my mouth the [__]
alcohol is not burnt off
it's [__] H Steve after Steve dismal
effort I want to find out if the other
chefs can do any better tuna is very
tasty you don't need that sauce for me
youve just [__] that dish by putting
that glue on there y that sort of galopy
stodgy wallpaper paste that in fact I'd
offer that to Daniela to [__] Plaster
the front of L Gonda you know that cuz
that looks like a pile of [__] there as
well what what's that what's that in
there inside yeah oh the chicken inside
yeah is this a Polish dish
no no the chicken's raw now um
unfortunately I uh I can't afford to
[__] off and die right now and I don't
want to catch salmonella in [__]
Derby so um put that straight in the bin
yeah yeah I've been poisoned once before
and it's not going to [__] happen
again it's so scary we really are in
trouble here I've never sent this
message out before in the R I tell them
[__] move your ass get on with it
otherwise you're out but I'm going to
tell you guys to stop
and give up don't fight it if you don't
want to change and with that change
comes in be prepared to work [__]
hard we've got to get rid of all this
crap we can't carry 80 89 dishes what's
it like when this man's off in the night
and you've got 25 books it must be mad
no when you cook like that do you
actually think that you're fit enough to
call yourself a chef if you're
defrosting things and deep fying
mushrooms and is it is it important for
you to cook or are you really seriously
interested in staying the way you are
cook you are you definitely want to
cook yeah away there's nothing
complicated in this yet the only option
is to go right back to basics I've
devised a new dinner menu That's so
simple hopefully it's foolproof a light
Noy with salmon and
taragan and a simple tomato and
mozzarella risoto that's a tomato juice
it's just a little bit too thick too
thick yeah even this kitchen surely
can't cook these dishes up where the
um then [__]
terrify fresh fragrant mix stand up
please Steve thank you g it's really
hard for you to understand at 19 how
modern we're trying to put the approach
yeah nothing's coming out of a [__]
packet nothing's coming out underneath
cooked [__] 3 days ago it's just
clean fresh and just think back to that
Phantom that
roller is it worth getting out of bed in
the morning yeah [__] right it is
good really easy okay yeah so it doesn't
all
[Music]
[Applause]
stick Dan he's never been given his own
section so I'm going to see how he does
with the vegetables you got to look out
them you know that almost as if you're
sort of in love with them yes beautiful
it's warming it it's very warm isn't it
huh Welcome to the Real World of the
kitchen big boy you're sweating yeah huh
that looks cool first time is it the
first time you sweat it in the kitchen
yeah good
man yep so now we've done the uh Peppers
yep the oine the butternut squash yes
and now all of a sudden Big Boy over the
last couple of hours yes you've been
running the vegetable section MH move
your
ass we now have a new contemporary menu
for the relaunch time to Chuck out the
chint Stella let me ask you something
your sat just come and touch us a minute
close your eyes and just touch it close
my eyes and touch it horrible [__]
disgusting dirty grubby smelly plastic
flowers yeah the Clutter on the tables
Martin look like it's all come out the
[__] pound shop you know you're like
an old [__] woman that just won't
throw anything away get rid of it going
tonight good it's like going to um an
airport lounge and looking at one of the
Chapels of rest it's the kind of thing
you'd see in there when you sort of sit
down and grieve I mean I'm sorry but
they're [__] awful catch get a hold
of them all and love them in the skip
yeah pleasure good man already I feel
like [__] hell I got rid of my
Granny's pants they're off they're no
longer up here I'm starting to think
about wearing a nice sexy pair of
knickers because I've just seen the
white tablecloths go down that's how I
feel in here it looks clean and fresh
would you wear knickers up to there
Stella oh don't start G stick to the
restaurant I'm just asking would you
wear a pair of B nickers up to here no
so get rid of the
flowers but I have discovered one thing
from the past worth hanging on to so
this is from the whole classic menu we
used to wear yeah all done the table all
done the table and now you stopped it
because it's on the mean at one time
Saturday night you used to just one
person just do the cooking all night so
you're taking that to what lightly brown
just nice and golden
brown I've asked Martin for a demo
because I think the fles are due for a
comeback
Jesus
Christ did you miss this oh yeah you're
so [__] good at it yes I hope so I
tried do me best
anyway but this should be the um
Hallmark of the restaurant this this is
Ely yes this is Art thank you pleasure
Christ almighty if they taste as good as
they look they going back on the
menu there a DI for they are [__]
delicious who needs a wine list when you
get pissed on the
dessert it's the day of the relaunch as
well as bringing back the fles I've
decided to resurrect the gonda's Dance
Floor a house band is booked and the
waiting staff finally looked the
part there will be 70 covers in tonight
double the numbers of diners that we had
in for the business
lunch it's a real test for the kitchen
they're really going to have to pull
together if they want to carry it
off I've put Danny in charge of the
staff dinner they don't normally have
them here but they're a great way to
build team what else have you got most
important thing about staff dinner big
boy is clearing out the fridge yes we
got to move now big boy we got 10
minutes to get this ready yes St I think
he could really take his uh his own
little sort of world there doing these
staff lunches and that you know that we
give him that little vote of confidence
yeah why
not unfortunately Steve doesn't seem
very confident with only an hour until
the first guests arrive I'm worried
you're running around getting all your
plates and bits and balls but I saw that
a week ago you're all boxed off no I I
was intending to go around in the mall
and just make sure everybody knows
what's what's going on tonight and what
I need when I shout for it what I want
when I want it it's all very well it's
in your mind but the problem saying I've
got to talk to them now sort of you know
yeah offloading it and get them to
understand sure sure there's a feeling
there but I'm not sure it's nervousness
or not I get stressed as much as anybody
else I'm only I'm only human so maybe I
get stress more than anybody else I
don't know M oh the is gorgeous
congratulations Daniel that's really
good Steve you're not eating well I've
had two meals since last Friday you've
had two meals since last Friday yeah I
just offered at the moment thank you I'm
really worried about Steve he seems very
very
nervous men we got yeah everything is in
place and Ready To Roll But at the last
minute Steve bottles it
right listen and I'm running the hot
plate tonight shouldn't really been
running the hot plate but Steve's asked
if I'd run the hot plate to make sure
that we get up to speed yeah
communication chemistry understanding
yeah working for each other yeah Gareth
yep what we're going to do tonight if
you get flustered and frustrated what
are you going to do ask for help yeah
and take it out on your what Pastor
that's right take out on your pastor not
Daniela enjoy it smile I'll be behind
you every ounce of the way smile
[Applause]
another order on one toal one palah ham
with fig one antipasta one Linguini main
course one Noy one tuna one salmon one
lamb not one [__] answer yes
chef thank you good boy I shouldn't be
doing this Steve needs to be able to run
his kitchen properly himself so I'm only
going to get him started so 3 minutes on
the hot plate one Noy one tuna one
salmon one lamb
Steve tomorrow you're on your own and I
just wish that you implemented a system
like this 10 years ago big boy you know
that I do so we be so [__] hard now
at the age of 51 yeah gotel thank you 14
go right G watch the cooking on the
pasta please yeah next time I'm going to
be down on your bollock two lamb one
riby one Chun yes sure yeah nicely put
on that PL nicely as if you're in love
with it yeah fresh t on the top come on
how does it feel to be cooking
normally no no no
different it's exciting once we get in
the system it be good y it's the only
way Steve yeah I can stay here and run
this but you're [__] benefit in Jack
[__] mate you're going to have to do it
yourself now you know that yeah run your
kitchen and run your team okay and if I
hear you silent I'm not talking to them
yeah hey I'm going to ram that fork up
your ass it's a big one yeah [__]
right
for the first time in 15 years Martin's
back cooking of a storm with the flbe
good music efficient and stylish table
service at last Londa is swinging
again three lamb two Riis one
tuner Hana can you send your honor in
please don't understand what all these
arrows mean so two medium one on that's
a medium is it
so your first main course is three lamp
that started clearing the starters yet
okay thank
[Music]
you as the atmosphere in the resturant
Hots up the kitchen is going into slow
motion no cross it off
what about that other table of four here
two ribby one tuna one salmon okay you
going all quiet salad
ready when the kitchen does get the food
out it's going down a treat I've never
seen a lady clean a plate so quick on my
life it's like taking a portable
dishwasher out for
dinner it's been beautiful really really
nice to enjoy authentic Italian cookie
very nice if they if they stand up the
reputation that they set tonight we'll
come
[Music]
back the new menu has been a success but
since I handed him the hot plate Steve
struggled and he's only got through it
by the skin of his
teeth come on Steve last table [__]
out right
Gare come in here Danny turn off the
stoves right how was that for you
truthfully could have been better huh
could have been better could have been
more smooth
more communication yeah yeah who can
that communication come from Steve me
hallelujah it's been a bloody hard week
but I think we've shown the staff that
the old gundler has life in her yet
[__] hell £2,000 in one night the
restaurant alone last week took 500 quid
now there's the insight to what this
place is capable of doing and it's only
down to one thing
what is it
Steve hard work that's all hard
work this kitchen was so far behind the
times even I considered throwing the
towel in we struggled through a birthy
function and then a business lunch but
the dinner dance showed how Londa can
get the good times
back I've implemented a new menu and a
new ethos in the kitchen but can they
really build on the momentum when I'm
not there to hold their hands
born in water Danny The Apprentice does
have the makings of a good Chef you've
seen over the week that you can cook in
the star food is a really nice thing for
you to do once a day huh I said to him
the other day I said I want to cook I
don't want to be light stuck on pots and
that no you're too good for that Gareth
also has a chance of making it if he
Knuckles down you've learned me more
stuff than he has in for years really
there's someone deep down inside there
that's tucked away that's dying to learn
wants to come out well wants to come out
so [__] get it out last but Steve
still worries
me I think you've [__] forgotten the
word cooking passion exciting yeah I
have you're right it's been switched out
for a long time it's all been rusted up
it's it's and this week's loosened not
it's it's it's just going to keep on
loosening up now I think I'm not going
to quit on it I'm going to give it my
[__]
best you if I don't come back [__] me
I'll be back yeah you come back whether
or not you'll be here when I get back
will be a different
[Music]
matter last summer I spent a week at
Londa in Derby my most testing kitchen
nightmare a restaurant 30 years out of
date it's like stepping back in time in
it is and I wondered whether should we
really decorate it or wait till the
fashion turns no
customers it has a [__]
reputation I'm one of the worst head
chefs I've ever met
for a 51y old Chef to produce that part
of [__] I'm [__] Gob smacked but
somehow I managed to get the place
swinging
[Applause]
again 4 months later I'm
back and someone's in the Gonda who on
Earth is that in there God
okay how are
you fine good quickies what's the matter
well i' have done my hair i' have got
changed you don't need to do that for me
Steve he's obviously getting ready for
dinner Steve left he walked out he
walked out gave me a week's notice as
soon as you left the minute I left he
walked out he didn't have the energy
thought about it and he was out of here
I I begged him to stay but he said now
his mind was made up I think he's got a
job in a pub now job in a pub yes
serving what kind of food well what the
general manager calls ding-ding food you
put in a microwave and out it com yeah
in a way I'm not that upset because if
he wasn't prepared to put on the rope
and actually help get the place back
who's in there now who's the chef oh you
have to see this man saved my life hello
Wayne how are you I'm not too bad at all
yeah Gordon nice to see you excellent so
the style of the menu what is the style
of the menu um style of menu but not
I've only arrived yesterday so so we've
had no sorry excuse me we've had no
chefs since no no no I did experiment
with at least four other chefs
I went through one who was fway who
would only cook in a
certain yeah even Wayne's pissing
himself did research it turns out
Daniela rot tested several head chefs
after Steve jumped ship at least she's
trying not to make the same mistake
twice Friday we had about 20 where with
Gareth he's still here no uh well he
finished up uh yesterday he's been
poached by Steve to go work in a pub
when he can work here but the money was
too much of a Temptation I'm afraid yeah
it's shocking I'm pissed off that Gareth
didn't stick it out but I think a clean
slate is the only way forward for
Daniela yeah someone was trying to
constantly pull constantly pulling the
wool over this woman's eyes and
unfortunately because she's so nice and
so gentle everybody was taking a piss
out of her and he becoming a laughing
stock abolutely now she got the ball by
the horns she shook it and she got rid
of the [__]
cobwebs please tell me Danny's here he's
working tonight he's working tonight uh
Danny have you missed me yes I have I
missed you too as well you know that big
man huh yes big
man little
[__] Danny's responded to my
encouragement and taking up new
responsibilities Daniel can you get the
cream please Daniel perhaps he and Wayne
are the dynamic duo that will give Londa
the stability that it desperately needs
on the bottom shelf Basel uh in the
packet yeah quick as you can please but
the proof in the
tasting I'm having Wayne's butternut
squash soup I hope it's better than
Steve's packet
Minon really nice color it smells
amazing and
um it's nice it's not difficult to make
a very simple homemade rustic
soup but it you know it speaks volumes
about a
restaurant they've built on the live
music theme Martin's still got his old
magic and he's now fling main courses as
well as
desserts looks fantastic y you sound
brilliant and it smells amazing yep you
taste it my very own Steak Diane
and steaks nice and rare The Taste is
exactly how it should be very
good Danielle has retained my simpler
more contemporary menu and they're
cooking with fresh ingredients rather
than opening a tin or a packet and the
Takens have quadrupled since it was last
here that was lovely and really pleased
it was lovely and you've got the
simplest things right well you've made
me feel very brave about it and I just
needed someone to open my eyes up to
what's dreams and what's realities thank
God she's woken up she thought she'd
bought success she'd bought a restaurant
full of baggage and a chef that didn't
give a [__] now she's got the basics
right she moves forward and this place
does have a chance of surviving for the
next 30 Years providing they continue
good food good service bit of atmosphere
and enjoy what you're doing it's not
difficult